What happens then? How many people living around, by the way?
I I don't know the population at all. No, I don't know the population.
You don't know the population of the country you seek to topple?
How many people living in Iran? 92 million. Okay. Yeah. I I How
could you not know that? I I don't sit around memorizing population
tables. Well, it's soon. Merch is coming soon. Okay. Merch is
coming soon. It'll be here. Why is it relevant whether it's 90
million or 80 million or 100 million? Why is that if you don't
know anything about the country? I didn't say I don't know anything
about Okay. What's the ethnic mix of Iran? They are Persians
and predominantly Shia. Okay. No, he's not even You don't know
anything about Iran. So, I
the Ben episode here. I think we're ready to move on, guys. We're
ready to move on and we can get to Tucker Carlson versus
Ted Cruz. Tucker Carlson versus Ted Cruz. Let's go. We haven't
seen it yet. Let me change the title up. Okay. Tucker Tucker
Carlson presses Ted Cruz on
uh intervention in
Middle East on his bloodthirst
for Israel. Uh no, no, no. Uh presses Ted Cruz on his need to
bomb Iran. Uh maybe that'll work. Yeah, that'll work. That'll
work as a title. Let's go. Tucker Carlson pressing Ted Cruz.
Let's do it. Tucker Cook Cruz. Yeah, we we watched uh we watched
the clip from yesterday. It was very good. Ted Cruz doesn't know
basic facts about Iran, but wants to do regime change in the
country. Very embarrassing for him. Okay. But I'm assuming that
the wider conversation also has like gems in it. Little nuggets.
Okay. Very much. Let's check it out. Time to have this conversation.
That's good to be with. So, you've come out for regime change
in Iran as distinct just from taking out the nuclear sites. What
does regime change look like in Iran? Somebody else in charge.
How do you get there? Look, that ultimately has to be a popular
uprising from the people. And it it's not a complicated question.
Is America better off with a country that has a leader who hates
us and want to kills, wants to kill us, or to have a country
with a leader who likes us and wants to be friends with us and
and Okay. So, regime change anywhere where there's a leader without
nukes who hates America. Is that is that what Ted Cruz is advocating
for? Cuz that's a lot more countries, Ted. Definitely. The latter
is better. Of course. And so that's not a complicated statement.
Look, I I believe you look across the world when you have countries
that have dictators that are Hey, remember that Saddam Hussein
guy who hated America and then they got rid of him. Whatever
happened to that country he ran? Iraq? I think Iraq. Iraq.
That that country loves America now, right? All those people
there, they love America now. Now that they don't have the bloodthirsty,
hateful Saddam.
Now, now that Saddam's not there, Iraq, Iraq loves America, right?
That's how that works. Viciously anti-America. Uh, Venezuela,
Maduro hates us. Would we we be better off with Maduro out of
power? Absolutely. I I want our enemies out of power and I want
our friends. Okay, so Ted is saying something and he's acting
like this is obvious. Guys, wouldn't we just not want these countries
to be run by people who hate the United States? And it's like,
yes, but you're that's not what you're advocating for. You're
you're like supporting regime change in these countries. Well,
yeah, but through popular uprising. Well, how are you getting
there? Well, through uh precision military strikes on a bunch
of their facilities. Oh, is the popular support there against
the United States or for the United States? Oh, it's against
it. So, why would they install a leader who likes the United
States? Oh, you have no reason to think that. Oh, okay. Thanks,
Ted. Thanks for playing, idiot. Who's in power? That I could
not agree more. The question is, how do you get there? Of course,
we've been trying to kill Maduro for quite some time. We have
troops there. I don't know that we've been trying to kill Maduro.
Yeah, we have. And um I think you know that and um I don't know
that. Okay. Well, we as a statement of fact we have. So we do
have massive sanctions. We tried to pressure him out of all.
I'm not aware of I'm just saying there's a lot of pressure coming
from various parts of the US government on that government and
it's still there. Yeah. Same the country of very ancestors Cuba.
You know 1959 we've been working on that. Hasn't worked. So it's
it's I we both agree it's hard to do it. It absolutely is hard.
And look I think you're reasonable to ask how do we produce that?
And and I think there's a distinction between what your objective
is and the means to get it. There are all sorts of things I would
say we would be better off we'd be better off in China without
shei there. Should we invade China and topple she? Of course
not. Better off with international debt. You know there are lots
of things. But but it's good to say all right what are our objectives?
And so with the Ayatollah in Iran saying you're for regime change
I I don't view as complicated. I mean the the guy literally leads
mobs.
Okay. But you are somebody who can vote on elements or vote on
actions from the United States that could lead to regime change.
Okay? You are an important voice in US politics. You saying you
support a regime change means something different than just going
like, "Well, do we like the leader there? Does the leader like
us?" No. Well, we should have a different leader.
Chanting death to America. So, so that's not good. Um, definitely
not good. Um, but the reason I think it's important to get a
little more detailed about how that might happen is because there's
military action in progress which we're supporting and the president
has said clearly including last night that he is focused on eliminating
the capacity of the Iranian government to produce nuclear weapons.
You are saying we need to use military force to affect regime
change. I have not said that. Oh, I'm I'm No, no. I I have not
not said that once. I I don't think we need to use military force
to do regime change. I said I support it. I would like to see
it happen. You asked me how should it happen. A popular uprising.
What? So what I've advocated for All right, let's step back a
second. You and I, we've known each other a long time. I would
say we agree on about 80% of the things on Earth for sure. And
there are a lot of things and and we can get into the nitty-gritty
of foreign policy as much as you want. There are a lot of things
on which you and I agree, not just a little bit, but violently.
I totally agree. Um I was rooting for you in your last campaign
for sure. Well, thank you. Look, you have been heroic on on the
border. You've been one of the clearest and and best voices in
the in the whole country on securing the border and and the absolute
crisis we're facing and in Texas I see it and live it every day.
Did he say they violently agree? Violently violent agreement.
Yeah. This uh basically we're arguing.
Um it's like a turn of phrase, right? A turn of phrase. No, that
seems like a little dog whistle. We're in viol we're in violent
agreement here. We're in ventilation. means that they both think
that some people need to die. Okay. I
Yeah, I don't I don't quite think so, but I respect I respect
the the shot. Okay. All right. All right. Speaking of people
needing to uh go. Sorry. Go. CCTV footage of the Iranian TV building
as it was.
If CCTV footage, they have CCTV cameras all over. Okay. All over
that building. And we can watch all the
So this is them yelling Allah. Why are they yelling it before
the strikes came
Wait, I think this is before the strikes came in. You can see
on the screen it's not like dusty yet.
air strikes are coming. Okay,
she made it. She made it. She didn't go
This guy, this guy's like,
I'm not letting this broadcast, but this guy is Oh my god.
Okay. Crazy crazy stuff. Sorry, back to this. Um, in CO, in fact,
wild, you may recall in the middle of the COVID lockdown, I was
out I hate the way Ted Cruz speaks. Okay, Ted Cruz's speaking
cadence is [__] up. Walking my dog when the whole
world was shut down and we were living in lunatic times and I
called you and said, "Tucker, your nightly monologues are the
single best thing on television." Like like I watched them like
like an injection of crack. Okay, I'm mixing my metaphor because
you don't inject crack. But but you get what I'm saying.
No, I mean it was you were standing up and speaking like what
the hell are we doing in a way that we desperately desperately
needed? And so whether it's securing the border, whether it's
the insanity of COVID lockdowns and the vaccine mandates, uh
whether it is the second amendment or the first amendment, you
and I agree on a ton of stuff. The 20% where we disagree, I I
do think is meaningful and and it's mostly in the foreign policy
space. And and what I would say, okay, you derive all of your
other positions from this America first ideology. You actually
agree with it to a large extent, Ted. Like you really do. Why
do you have why is this America first? All you have to do is
explain why serving Israel's interests primarily over the US
over US interests or you can argue why the US needs Israel. But
you have to you have to explain it. You can't just ignore it
because it seems to be outlying, right? It outlies your other
positions pretty significantly. If you'll allow me to get a little
theoretical and then I'll I'm happy to get specific. For a long
time, people have perceived
two different polls of Republican foreign policy. There have
been interventionists
and those have been people like John McCain and and Lindsey Graham,
George W. Bush. Uh, and there have been isolationists and then
the most prominent of those have been Ron Paul and Rand Paul
and and there others and and people perceive those are the two
choices. You got to be one or the other. I've always thought
both were wrong. I I don't agree with either one. Um, the way
I view my own foreign power. I'm I'm with you, by the way, for
whatever it's worth. I I agree with you. I don't know who set
up that binary, but there are lots of choices actually. I mean,
people sort of naturally fall into I think they want to classify
people and they're like, "Okay, you're one or the other and you
got to be all or nothing." And and and
the interventionists, it seems, have never seen a country they
didn't want to invade. And that doesn't make any sense to me.
What is this relevant to? Why Ted This is Ted Cruz is just like
an evolved version of counterpoints. He always does this. He's
always got these stupid anecdotes. And it's like, dude, just
make your point. You don't have to explain to me that interventions
interventionist exists and then historic examples and define
it. Just make your point and the isolationist I think don't take
the threats to America seriously and and I think that's naive
and it doesn't work and and so my view I I consider myself a
third point on the triangle and and what I describe like he's
got a third position. I've always thought, you know, some people
suggest online. I've always thought they were crazy, but Ted's
like, I've got something of a third position on this. That as
is that I am a
hawk, which which sounds a little weird, but but what do I mean
by that? I mean, I mean, I'm just going to do whatever Trump
says because he's got something on me. Um, that's honestly what
it means. He just gave So, hawks are people who don't want or
hawks are people who want to fight and then non-intervention
is hawk. I just want to huck bombs at other countries versus
doves.
Yeah. Well, the non-intervention, it's isolationist versus war
hawk, right? Yeah. Isolationist would be more of like doves,
people who don't want to get involved in wars. Yeah. And then
hawks would be the the interventionists. But he's saying there's
an option where you could be not interventionist, but a hawk,
as in like, I'm totally down with us drone striking all these
people. I just don't want to get in any wars. No boots on the
ground. Okay. That's basically what he's saying. I think like
the term for it though politically is um being a liar. Yeah.
Sure. Yeah. cuz he totally supports like and then he comes out
and says, "Well, no, I totally support regime change in Iran."
No, I don't want to I don't want to put boots on the ground,
but I totally if we could just, you know, help Israel a little
bit in the central touch point for US foreign policy and for
any question of military intervention
should be the vital national security interest of the United
States. Oh, he's going to make your argument, Jerry. He's going
to say, "This country tried to kill our president. We have to
do something. We have no choice. we're forced to respond. How
does this make America safer? How does this protect Americans?
If it does, we should be strong. And actually, another way of
conceiving what I'm saying. I'm It's a reasonable argument. You're
the person who we have to No, I didn't propose it. I didn't say
we have to do this because we're trying to kill Trump. I said,
"Doesn't it make sense if our government if the if our own intel
says that these people keep trying to kill our president? That
would just make sense why we wouldn't intervene in somebody else
attacking them." Oh, sure. You have a less you you think the
intervention should be less like just not stopping Israel. But
I I thought I meant like the point of like that's a threat to
American national security. That's what I just hadn't heard that
point from somebody else. I heard from you first. That's all.
But um and everything is like confusing over there because you've
got certain groups that are like like sometimes you say this
is a militia group, this isn't the government and then this is
their government or like what is it? Hezbollah is not actually
part of this government body. Like how do you pinpoint Yeah.
Like how do you pinpoint some of these threats coming from certain
countries on like the actual government? All of it just sounds
so complicated to me to ever be like, "Yeah, you should attack
Iran." Yeah, sure. And then there's the predicament where it's
like, why do we Then there's the predicament that we brought
up last night where it's like, why do we even know that Iran
threatened Trump's life numerous times?
We normally don't get that sort of intel. Yeah. Which, yeah,
that obviously in and of itself seems like it could be weird.
Hey, the country that, you know, all the pe I'm going to sound
so bad. All the people who donate to me, the country that they
all want invaded, they happen to try to kill me a bunch of times.
Trust me, guys, they tried it. They never fired any shots or
anything, but they tried to kill me a bunch of times. It's vital
to our national security. I I feel like I hear Trump making this
argument. Yeah. Like I don't know what the truth is or what's
a lie or what's being um played up, but it could be seen as uh
similar to weapons of mass destruction. Like here is a reason
for you to be angry at this
Yeah. Exactly. And it kind of works. It could especially I think
it could help soothe his base in terms of uh like helping Israel
strike Iran and and execute or effectuate regime change in Iran.
So yeah, I'm I'm interested to see which way Ted goes here. Us
we should be strong and actually another way of conceiving what
I'm saying. I'm speaking theoretically,
but but Reagan referred to it as peace through strength. and
and actually
I think Donald Trump's foreign policy is very much what I'm describing
a non-interventionist hawk where
he understands that and I think this is historically true
the best way to avoid war is being strong that weakness and isolationism
I think encourages war so it can going back to
regime change where you started in Iran or just I I don't think
I disagree with anything you've said, so we may not be that far
apart. Really? Yeah. Tucker's going to go, "Okay, nothing you
said is wrong there, but you also haven't said anything like
tangible about what you think America's actions here should be.
How about you say what you think the actions of America should
be here, and we can work from there. Stop just bloiating over
like the circumstances under which you make decisions.
Go say something. say something because you said that the single
criterion for making decisions about America's foreign policy
is America's national interest. Yes, that's it. Yeah. Which is
also America first. That's another way of putting that as well.
The definition of it. It's hardly breaking news. The US dollar
has been gravely
from Are we watching that now? So, I think we are and and
from what you've said publicly, I think on Iran in particular,
you and I disagree. And all right, let me contrast it when Obama
was president. When Obama was president, you remember he talked
about wanting to have military action against Syria. And at the
time, I tried to keep an open mind to it. I said, "Okay, let
me listen to the commander-in-chief described to me how this
is in America's interest and what your plan is." And and Bashar
Assad was a bad guy. He was killing his own citizens and and
he had chemical weapons that were very dangerous. I could conceive
of a commander-in-chief laying out a plan for, okay, we're going
to go in and say, "Grab the chemical weapons and leave." Like,
I could see that I if there was a real threat to America and
there was a plan to to prevent that, I could see supporting that.
So, I wanted to hear what he had to say. And I listened both
in classified briefings and and public questioning. And number
one, their public defense of it was incoherent. So, so John Kerry
said, "We're going to engage in an unbelievably small strike."
I think that's a quote. I'm like, "Okay, and and to do what?"
At the time,
there were nine major rebel Islamic groups in Syria. I'm like,
"Okay, I agree. Bashar Assad's a bad guy. You topple him." And
one of the nine other groups takes over. Seven of them were affiliated
with radical Islamic terrorism. You had al-Qaeda and al-Nusra.
I'm like, "Wait, how is it better
to have lunatics who hate us in charge?" Yes. Well, Ted Cruz
is laying out the primary issue with regime change in the Middle
East. Okay. Most of the people who don't have control of their
countries. Okay, lots of those people just hate the US. The US
has been doing a lot of a lot of really [__] [__]
in the Middle East for the sake of oil for decades. Not a lot
of people like America there. Pretty much any regime change you
do, you're putting somebody in power who odds are they could
hate the US even more than whatever leader they have. Assad's
a bad guy, but I don't want worse guys in charge.
Obama administration couldn't give an answer to that.
And ultimately when you press them, John Kerry in particular
I pressed and he would say well we need to defend international
norms like what the hell is an international norm? I don't know
what it is but I'm not interested in putting US service men and
women in harm's way to defend one. Amen. So I opposed this the
Syria attack and and and opposed it vocally.
And
I I'll say Ted Cruz is building this up as if he has a really
wellthoughtout understanding of the Middle East and that he's
going to have a really like everything he's saying here, these
feel like reasons you should ask about why we want a regime change
in Iran. Right? So if he's got answers to all of these questions
for Iran and he knows exactly what's going to happen, I'm listening.
I Okay.
Rand and I agreed. Rand's a friend of mine, but we we agreed
with that position for different reasons.
What I was asking is is I think the question we should ask, how
does this make America safer? The Obama administration couldn't
give me an answer, so I posed it. I think Iran is very different.
Let me ask what you how how
Okay, so I just got to link this right off the off the top of
my dome here. Senator Ted Cruz on uh Senator Ted Cruz in 2013
on Obama's attacking Syria. The residual presidential authority
to act militarily in the absence of a declaration of war is based
on an imminent direct threat to the United States. Acting would
be contrary to the Constitution. Senator Ted Cruz 2025 on Trump
attacking Iran. But some Republicans are giving the green light
to Trump. A single bombing run historically has not been understood
to require congressional authorization. Asked if the president
needs congressional approval to launch strikes on Iran, Senator
Lindsey Graham told Axio simply no. So basically, the residual
presidential authority to act militarily in the absence of a
declaration of war is based on an imminent direct threat to the
United States, but he totally forgot what he said in 2013. He
totally ignores it. Doesn't bring anything else up here. Just
says, "No, bombing run's not that bad. No, bombing runs, guys.
Bombing run's not that bad."
The Israel Iran war has spread to the streets of New York City.
I love Israel for people. It's a disgrace.
It's a gun. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Police. Yo, police.
Why are they in the street? What the? Okay.
New Yorkers are crazy. New Yorkers are crazy. You think of how
Syria wound up because Bashar Asad now lives in Moscow. Yeah.
He was taken out by our allies. Um, and he's been replaced by
a radical Islamist who was affiliated with ISIS. So, is that
a win or no? Unclear. Look, Syria is a mess. So I've consist
Ted Cruz thinks it's a win because it allowed them to go and
take out all of uh Syria's anti-air, clear out Syria so that
Israel can now strike into Iran. Ted Cruz unironically thinks
that's a massively opposed. But we had a secular leader in a
religious and ethnically diverse country. Now we have a religious
extremist, Islamic religious extremist who's overseen the purge
of of Christians and Alawites. Is that better? That doesn't seem
Well, look, one of the things you said is you said he was taken
out by our allies. I don't think that's right. Israel. That is
100% correct. Uh, that is 100% correct. What the are you saying?
Turkey is an ally of the United States. Okay. Not the not the
most reliable of allies, but I believe Turkey had a massive hand
in this. The US had a hand in it and Israel had a hand in it.
Basically, every every group there suddenly was like, "Oh, uh,
let's go get Assad right now." I believe it was Turkey, Turkish
interests that funded and pushed a lot of that. at last I read,
but that was when the that was when Assad was toppled. I'm not
totally sure exactly like how that ended up happening, but
uh I should watch a retrospective. I bet there's good retrospective
videos on it now. From what I understand, it was Turkish influence
that pushed that at the time it happened. But there are US allied
forces there who were a part of it. Also, from what I understand,
didn't take Assad out. What happened? And I'll tell you, what
about Turkey? Turkey didn't take him out. So, is it Who knows?
Interesting. I had a long How did Assad get kicked out? A piss.
Yeah. When when Netanyahu was in DC a couple of months ago. That's
not an answer. What the That's not an answer to the question.
How did Assad get kicked out? Ted Tucker just called you on your
and you just you just totally pivoted. Well, you see, when Netanyahu
was in DC a couple months ago, he and I sat down for a couple
of hours. He's a good friend of mine and and we talked actually
about Syria. It was he made an interesting point that I've not
heard anywhere else in that he said he believes what toppled
Assad
was when Israel took out Nazala. Nazallah was the head of Hezbollah
and they took him out and he and and he made an interesting point.
He said it's fascinating how Yeah. You also crippled half of
Hezbollah's like command infrastructure and Hezbollah was absolutely
somebody that made that helped uh what do you call it? reinforce
Assad's grip on the region and by through Hezbollah focusing
on Israel instead of Syria. Yeah, that was a massive part of
his fighting force. I believe Hezbollah trained a lot of the
Syrian army, right? Like the Syrian army was actually getting
um like they were a lot of green recruits. There's a lot they
don't have like a massively loyal army and I think Hezbollah
was training a lot of them because Hezbollah has had a lot of
experience fighting. Yeah, I I could believe that. and Israel
crippling like half Hezbollah's entire command structure probably
prevented them from going in to help in any way. Charismatic
leader and and BB said look Nazala was a very effective terrorist
leader and when they took him out that power base was supporting
Assad
and that ultimately in BB's analysis removed the support for
from Assad and and toppled him but they weren't trying to take
out Assad. My view now I don't know. I but so you don't think
that and I I don't it is very confusing and I I don't know that
anyone really knows all the details but you don't think that
Israel or Turkey our NATO ally Turkey played any role in toppling
Assad? I I don't know I don't know that they did. Look look my
Yes, he does. This is just lying. This this would me off if I
was Tucker because this is just known right like people talk
through back channels and intelligence. It is just straight up
known that it was a Turkish funded group, like a Turkishbacked
group that went through and was the primary force like moving
through Syria. I I'm pretty sure that's known. I don't know how
I would know that and say it and then Tucker would know that
too, right? Like there would probably I'm guessing they had Turkish
weapons. It's the same way you know that the Houthies get funded
by Iran, right? They're holding a bunch of Iranian weapons and
yeah, we know where you're getting your from. I can see the I
can see what what kind of weapon it is, right? and and pretend
to just go, "Well, I don't really know what happened there."
Yeah, you do. Of course you do. You were just talking to BB Netanyahu
a couple months ago. Close friend of yours. I think BB Netanyahu
probably has an interest in the in the happenings of the region.
I'm guessing you guys talked about understanding of that. They
clearly took out Naza and Hezbollah. They've decimated Hezbollah,
but Hezbollah is waging war on them. So, so decimating Hezbollah
was very good for Israel and very good for for America, too.
I mean, Hezbollah hated us. Um, I disagree with Assad in the
category of an unintended consequence. And whether it's good
or bad, I don't know. I I think time will tell for the United
States. Yeah. For the United States. I think time will tell the
new leadership there. You're right to be concerned. I I
Let me step back. Uh Tucker could Tucker is being nice. By the
way, if Tucker wanted to step on uh if he wanted to kneel down
on Ted's neck right now, he would say, "Oh, so it's like not
a problem for you that Christians are being like by Islamic terrorists
in Syria, that's fine with you." Assad held that back and now
a whole bunch of Christians, your fellow Christians are being
He could kneel on Ted right now, but he's not going to. He's
being nice. Wait until he asks Ted the population. Let's talk
regime change generally. I I mentioned Syria. I I also oppose
the Iraq war. I think the Iraq war was a serious mistake
and and we have a pattern and going back to this binary of the
interventionist and and the isolationists. The interventionists
advocate over and over again there's a bad guy. There's a dictator
who's who's doing bad things to his people and they say let's
go topple them and you have dictators in the Middle East who
are that's not true. Actually, most interventionists actually
don't really give a about those leaders doing bad things. There's
leaders doing bad things all over the planet. It's when leaders
are doing bad things that you could justify it to people and
do something in the American interest or in like your private
interest as well, right?
Like, oh dude, why are we pretending that it was in America's
interest to go toppel Saddam or that Saddam was toppled only
because of the bad things he was doing? There's a there's like
a litany of factors there. Let's not pretend the interventionists
are just like dogooders. They're not. Radical Islamic terrorists.
We come in and topple them. The radical Islamic terrorists take
over and they start Americans. And mind you, how the heck does
that help us? Like
Saddam Hussein was a horrible human being. He murdered and tortured
people. I unequivocally bad guy, but it got much worse after
we toppled him. And you ended up having ISIS rise up. I mean,
that was the cause of ISIS was toppling. Please, for the love
of God, ask Ted who the intelligence came from that said Saddam
Hussein might have had WMDs. Please, Tucker, please ask him where
the intelligence came from that Saddam Hussein had weapons of
mass destruction. Please, please, please, please. I need Ted
to answer that question right now while he justifies going to
war with Iran. Saddam Hussein. Same thing in in in Libya. You
had Gaddafi, another horrible guy
that that under Obama we toppled him and you ended up having
radical Islamic war. I'm pretty confident if I'm not mistaken,
Barry Q, that the source for that intelligence was Israel. I'm
pretty confident. It might have come through Britain, but the
source for it was Israel. Lords taking over and and so or I'm
uh or I'm like totally misinformed and totally conspiratorial.
Uh if you have if you have evidence that it was not sourced from
Israel, I would take that. But I I believe that's what I'd read.
I think I've read that multiple times like
over the years. So if I'm wrong on that, I'd like to know. So,
if you can find me information that it wasn't, uh, I'd appreciate
that. The and it's the question I asked in Syria. Okay. Well,
what's the plan?
And and and how is this good or bad for the United States? And
and so I don't think with Iran, I I view Iran as very different
from Iraq. But up to that point, you say we disagree. I I don't
hear really anything. I'm not quite sure what happened in Syria,
but I I don't know. So, right. But other than that, I don't hear
anything I disagree with at all. Yeah. Sounds like we're in a
complete agreement. I wonder though, is there a successful regime
change that the United States supported that you're aware of
in the last 100 years? Sure. Uh defeating the Soviet Union and
the Soviet Union collapsing, winning the Cold War, that that
was the most
step for US national security interests of our lifetimes. Okay.
And so you would classify that as a regime change that we affected?
Absolutely. Okay. Uh, and look, you you and I are are in my office.
We're sitting uh next to a painting of of Reagan in front of
the Brandenburgg gate and and up top. Dude, Tucker looks so confused
at this whole thing. Just Tucker's doing the face the entire
time that he's like, "What? Why the are you yapping in all these
different directions?" Uh, are the words tear down this wall
uh in German
in the style of the graffiti. Right. And I think those are the
most important words any leader has said in modern times. And
and if if you look at how Reagan waged the Cold War and and Reagan
is very much my model for how to I actually think how Reagan
took on the Soviet Union is exactly how we should take on China.
Now starting from the point, look, Reagan was not an interventionist.
In 8 years, the biggest country Reagan ever invaded was Grenada.
He was very reluctant to use US military force. He didn't respond
after the 83 barracks bombings. You're right. He he made the
judgment that the risk exceeded the benefits and and that's a
very rational decision to make and and it's reflected Trump has
made those same decisions where he is willing to use military
force but but he very much asks okay is this
it sucks cuz Ted actually speaks quickly but I don't want to
speed him up but I'm like I'm like he's he's doing he's actually
doing like a Nick Lee thing where he's like making me want to
tune out um because he just keeps yapping in different directions
instead of answering any questions. I do wish Tucker would kind
of press him a little bad for America. Does this endanger US
servicemen and women or not? And one of the points about the
Cold War, look, nobody in their right mind wanted a shooting
war between America and the Soviet Union. The two biggest nuclear
powers on Earth firing bullets at each other is really unhealthy
for human beings.
Same thing is true with Okay, I'm sorry. Uh Iraq were a mistake.
Do we get an answer from Ted? were horrified in simplicity
and I back story. Yes. So three times the state department deleted
those words from that speech and three times Reagan wrote it
back speech. The Berlin wall was torn down. It was all set up
person I don't think. Oh sure. Uh but I mean just the basic metrics
debt life expectancy. It was I wonder why after that victory
America didn't thrive in the way that we thought that it would
that I thought that it would. I was involved in that. I mean
we're very focused on my house one and I I wonder two things.
Why didn't the United States kind of declare victory and make
some sort of uh arrangement with Russia that allowed like mutual
prosperity rather than continuing a cold war? And second, I wonder
why the United States didn't get a lot better. Like why don't
we have better infrastructure? Why don't we have fewer homeless?
Why do we have all these drugs? Like if we won, why does our
country look like this? I walked across from Union Station this
morning as you do, I'm sure, every day. And all those people
lying in the street and sleeping outside. It's like what is that?
We're sorry to say it, but this is not really dangerous forces
in our society. Some of it is politics and some of it is culture.
And one of them is why aren't US politicians focused on fixing
America's problems? Why are they focused on fixing other countries
problems? I don't super care. How much money is the US sending
to Israel is the next question that comes up that I think is
relevant to our country. The the dollar spent, the aid package
Ukraine to pay the retirement of civil servants in a country
that we have nothing to do with. The endless support for Israel
very expensive when people are literally buying groceries on
credit in the United States. Can you feel like it nothing against
Ukraine or Israel? All right, let's stop. You said the support
for Israel very expensive. How much support do we give to Israel?
Why did Ted Ted just blew past Ukraine? He's like, "Yeah, Ukraine's
a total waste of money." Wait, why did you say that it's a waste
of money to send it to Israel? Hold on. What? Wait, what? Well,
you tell me. You vote for it. Yeah, it's about 3 billion a year
is the military assistance. Was that the only assistance? Yeah,
we we just have military assistance. Israel does not have additional
assistance. There's there's an MOU, a memorandum of understanding,
and it's 3 billion a year. So, what is it costing to support
the bombing campaign to protect Israel right now? um from Iran.
So, I don't know right now, but I'll tell you this. Let's go
back to the Touchstone. Oh, yes. Ted, don't you understand that
we also shoot down missiles attacking Israel? Like, it cost us
more money than just the amount sent to Israel in aid to defend
Israel. Foreign policy. How much money does it cost to sit the
USS Gerald Ford off the coast of Israel in the Mediterranean?
Probably expensive. Ted policy American interest. Our support,
our military support for Israel is massively in America's national
security and it benefits us enormously. Well, before we can before
we can make independent judgments about whether or not that's
true, I'm certainly open to it. I think we need to know what
it costs. So, what's the annual cost of defending Israel? Do
you know three billion a year? The aid, but I mean the U the
cost of the weapons for example, the cost of US personnel there,
the cost of moving ships to the region, which we're doing right
now. Oh, look,
all of that. Do we know what the cost is? So, look, the last
week I don't know. and and there's some lag when the administration
but the last two years t it's under the constitution the commander-in-chief
has control of the armed forces and so President Trump has made
some decisions that we'll know the cost over time but I don't
know the last week that that I I don't have visibility on that
the annual cost is 3 billion that's that's it's a 10-year memor
no that is weapons sold that is not keeping US personnel US equipment
in the region that the US owns and maintains of understanding
and that's that's the principal driver of the cost but let me
make a point we get mass massive benefit. Um, evil Johnny Bravo.
No, not necessarily. I mean, you might have the I don't know
if it costs more to keep the Gerald Ford sitting there. I don't
actually know where it sits most of the time. I think it usually
is deployed in the Mediterranean anyway, right? One of these
one of these uh carrier strike groups is usually deployed in
the Mediterranean. I think I think they moved a second one in
or moved one up into the Red Sea. That was not usual. That usually
sits like further south. How much more that costs, I'm not totally
sure. It definitely costs a lot more to fly out in interceptors
or to fly jets off of these things to go and intercept rockets
headed towards Israel though. Benefits from Israel. Israel shares
the MSAD is one of the best intelligence sources on the planet.
The enemies of Israel, the people who Oh, he's trying to bait
Tucker into talking about 9/11. You won't catch Can't Tuck, bro.
Tucker won't fall for that one. Israel, they all hate us. It
It's almost a perfect overlap. And so if we tried to recreate,
if we're just trying to defend America, we tried to recreate
the national security benefits of our alliance with Israel, it
would cost, I don't know, 30 billion, 300 billion.
By the way, uh Tucker is not going to ask, but I wonder why the
US also sent, you know, they only sent three billion in aid to
Israel, but why do they send so much aid to all of the countries
around Israel?
What is that about? Someone explain to me what that's about.
Hello. According to a report from Axio, US President Trump has
is said to have doubts about whether the US Air Force's
massive ordinance penetrator would actually be able to reach
and destroy Fordo fuel enrichment plant, Iran's primary facility
for enriching weapons grade uranium, which is believed to be
up to 90 m deep inside a mountain near the city of K in northern
Iran. Trump is said to have specifically asked his military advisers
over the last few days about whether a 30,000 pound bunker buster
would be capable of destroying the Ford nuclear facility with
defense officials telling the president they were confident it
would. Though it's not known if President Trump was convinced
the bunker buster will work. It's not a capabilities issue. We
have the capability, but there's an entire plan for a possible
attack. It's not just drop a bunker buster and declare victory.
A top US official said is uh Israeli officials believe that the
United States will eventually join the war and assist with the
destruction of the Fort facility, but contend they could focus
they could cause significant damage to the underground complex
even if forced to go it alone. One option could be a commando
raid against the Ford nuclear facility by Israeli special forces,
similar to an operation seen last September where Israeli forces
raided and destroyed an underground missiles facility uh an underground
missile facility to the north of the Syrian capital of Damascus.
A US official said the Israelis told the Trump administration
that they would not be able to reach deep enough into the mountain
with bombs. They may do it with humans. Oh Jesus, Trump, my Okay.
All right. Good one. Uh, how many of these bad boys do we have
stockpiled? The bunker busters? Probably a lot. Probably like
a ton. Probably enough that the you won't be paid for the ordinance
really. You honestly it's going to be cheaper to drop the ordinance
than to decommission it. Except when you I mean aside from the
fuel cost for the B2,
but it's probably not that much. It's pro. There's probably quite
a few of those. Um anyway, that's weird that Trump would say
I'm not sure if we can do it. I also don't know if this is suggesting
that the US might think about helping with this. I hope not.
I really hope not. Okay. I hope not. Can you elaborate? And again,
I'm going into this as someone who's always liked Israel um and
still does, but I also think at this point, given where we are,
it's fair to ask rational questions about what the benefits are.
Good. Um,
so does MSAD share all of its intelligence with us? Oh, probably
not, but they share a lot. Um, we don't share all of our intelligence
with them, but we share a lot. It's a close allian. Do they spy
domestically in the United States? Oh, they probably do, and
we do as well. And and friends and allies spy on each other,
and I assume I assume all of our
Wait, why does that serve the US interest? Uh, well, MSAD's one
of the greatest spy agencies in the world. Do they spy against
the United States? Yeah, probably. Allies spy on us. That's okay
with you. You know what? One of the things about being a conservative
is that you're not naive and utopian. You you don't think humans
are all part of the reason socialism doesn't work is is the the
the mantra from each according to his abilities to each according
to his uh Ted should Tucker should ask next who do you think
spies more in the US? Who do you think works in terms of intelligence
against US interests more often? Canada or Israel? Doesn't work.
As a conservative, I assume people act in their rational self-interest.
Is it conservative to pay people to spy on you? It's conservative
to recognize that human beings act in their own self-interest
and every one of our friends spies on us. And I'm not Do you
like it? That's my question. I'm not asking whether they have
motive to do it. Of course they do. I understand that and I I'm
not mad at them. But you're an American law. Does Canada have
MSAD? Canada has an intelligence agency. The question is, are
they spending resources for that intelligence intelligence agency
to spy on the other country and the leaders of that country,
politicians in that country? Would there be any programs like
that? And I'm sorry, it sounds conspiratorial, but Israel does
do that. And they are very concerned about what's going on in
a lot of other countries in a way that most Western countries
don't spend money spying on each other. It's just not quite the
same. America might spend that money spying on other Western
countries, but most other Western countries don't. We give Canada
billions for a year for free. Well, that's also true. So, I just
want to know Hold on. I want to know your attitude. You said
that your guiding principle, in fact, the only principle, the
only criterion I said guiding, the overwhelming, I wouldn't say
only. Is is it in America's interest? Is it in America's interest
for Israel to spy on us, including on the president? Um, it is
in America's interest to be closely allied with Israel because
we get huge benefits for it. And you want us want to see the
clear but I just want to stop on the swing for a second that
it it takes place as you know um including on the president of
the United States and several presidents. And I just want to
know if that's okay. And why is it okay? Wouldn't an American
lawmaker say to a client state, "You're not allowed to spy on
us. I'm sorry. I know why you want to. I'm not mad at you, but
you're not allowed to. And I don't care for it. I don't want
to be spied on by you." Is that It's kind of weird not to say
that, but you don't seem able to say that. Sure. I would say
don't spy on us. They're going to anyway. And by the way, the
Brits are, the Canadians are like, I don't think Well, I'm not
for that at all. I think it's disgusting, but we don't actually
pay their, you know, we're not their most meaningful sponsor.
We're not paying for the operations of the Brit. So, I got to
say, and this is it, it's weird. We're talking about isolationist.
The obsession with Israel. Why is Israel Well, I don't think
I'm obsessed with Israel. Okay, but I think a lot of people are.
And like the question, Israel spies on us. Well, so does every
other country. Why are you mad at Israel? I guess. Oh, no. No.
I'm I'm hardly the one who's I've never taken money from the
Israel lobby. Have you? Taking money from the Israel APAC. So,
Apac raises a lot of money for me. But it's Tucker's winning
pretty hard. This is pretty funny. But I will say this is a good
question. It's like what does Israel do that's different, right,
than other countries? I'd say I wouldn't want to give the Saudis
money either.
Uh Ted had to Ted had to admit it there. It's actually a misnomer
because the people who raise money are individuals. So it's not
the pack itself, but they're individual members who believe in
the American Israeli uh friendship. A pack a foreign lobby. No,
it's an American lobby. It's the Apac stands for the America
Israeli political action. What does it lobby for? So to be honest,
not a whole lot effectively. Listen, I came in to to Congress
uh based on how on how far you're willing to go to debase yourself
in this interview, I feel like they paid for your soul, Ted.
13 years ago with the stated intention of being the leading defender
of Israel in the United States Senate and I've worked every day
to do that. Apac a lot of times Apac I wish were much more effective
like
swamp of terrified of Apac and Apac I'm not terrified of Apac
at all. I'm you're the one who seems a little uncomfortable when
I'm asking. No, not uncomfortable at all. I'm just asking what
Apac does. My understanding having known a lot of
lobbies on behalf of the Israeli government. Oh, okay. America
has thousands of colleges and universities and a lot of no why
economics are a country better zero cost took a position truth
that's tucker for hillhillsdale.com to enroll for free when was
the last time Apac took a position that deviated from prime minister
Nanyahu all the time
okay let me go back and get a little history if you want to do
a deep no don't give me history Tucker you fell for this with
Putin do not fall for it with Ted Cruz no history the time for
history lessons has ended the time for speaking Your mind is
now. Ted, speak. Say something.
Oh, I just muted it. Okay, let me go back and get a little history.
If you want to do a deep dive on APC, I don't I want to do a
shallow dive. No, no, no, no. I want I want to get to the core
question. Apac is lobbying for a foreign government. And I don't
it's not it's lobbying for the United States. It is lobbying
for a strong USIsraeli relationship. Okay. And so it's not has
nothing to do with foreign government.
It it it wants America and Israel to be closely allied. Okay.
But it's lobbying on and that that is a 50-50 relationship as
in the same amount of money that they spend in America lobbying
for Israeli interests. They spend in Israel lobbying for American
interests or half of the interests of another country. So that's
not true at all. And and if not true. No. And how much contact
do you think Apac leaders have with the government of Israel?
No idea. I imagine some I think the government of Israel is often
frustrated with Apac. Do you think not nearly strong enough?
Do you think there's any coordination between the government
of Israel and Apac? Do they talk? Sure. If you're lobbying for
more US Mexico trade, would you talk to people in the US and
Mexico and the government? Sure. Like, like if So, yeah, but
where's the American Canadian trade pack that is only Americans
lobbying for more trade with Canada? Where does that exist? And
does it have the same impact that Apac does? Apac's not illegal,
but it is very effective in what it does. And it is sort of like
a loophole in some way. It's very It's just I don't know why
Ted can't just just answer the questions, Ted. Just I'm not mad
about that. There are a million countries that lobby Washington.
I like a lot of those countries, including Okay, but APE are
Americans, but not Hold on. There are tons of Americans who lobby
on behalf of foreign governments. I know them. I'm related to
some of them. I know how it works. I'm from here. So, my question
is not is it outrageous that foreign governments lobby the United
States? They all do. Okay. Including Israel. My only question
is why don't we admit that is what's happening. You're denying
it, but it's true. And what you're saying is false. Why aren't
they registered as a foreign lobby? Because they're not. They're
not a foreign lobby. No, they're not. And and this is there's
a fever swamp. Look, it's not a fever swamp. These are very reasonable
questions. And you've accused me of being obsessed with Israel,
which I'm not. I actually haven't. I've been feverish about it,
which I'm not at all. I'm just I find it it's a very tender spot
when you ask it. And I don't know why. So Tucker Tucker, by the
way, now Tucker is the one who's not being honest. Tucker knows
exactly why this is a tender spot. Okay? Because the only way
to really shut down questioning about Apac and a lot of the stuff
around it is to go, "Uh, sound a little anti-semitic there, [__]
Maybe you should take your questions elsewhere." That's the way
you dodge these questions. Okay. Ted Cruz can't do that. Ted
Cruz is sitting here on a in an interview. He to actually answer
like specifically.
All right, let's go back. I was first elected to the Senate in
2012. I came in in Obama's second term. And I actually saw Apac
be badly wounded in a way they never came back from. And and
the second term is when Obama did the Iran nuclear deal. And
and the Iran nuclear deal, I think, was catastrophic.
And Apac went all in lobbying against it. Yeah. And they failed.
And and I was the leading opponent of the Iran new Oh, I know.
They definitely failed. Yes, they failed. And what happened?
The Obama White House told every Democrat. When I got here, there
used to be real bipartisan support for Israel. That has largely
disappeared.
And it that's just completely patently false. That's a completely
insane thing to say. I'd say the same number of people in the
Republican party that like hardcore MAGA winging, you know, the
Marjgery Taylor Greens of the world and the people in the Democrat
party like Ilan Omar and maybe you could say AOC that a's been
pretty pro- Israel a lot of the time. These would be the people,
but they're outliers. They're still broad bipartisan support
for it's the Obama nuclear deal that caused it because the Obama
White House told every Democrat, pick you either stand with Israel
or you're a Democrat and you stand with the Obama White House.
that almost every single Democrat member of Congress said, "I'm
a Democrat first to hell with Israel."
They probably said, I would imagine the Obama White House said
something like, "We're going to make you answer questions on
why you're going to try to shut down this nuclear deal. Okay,
we'll we'll actually ask you these questions. We'll primary you."
It's probably something like that. And then I watched as Apac
every one of those Democrats got reelected and Apac did nothing
about it. And and it dramatically reduced Apac's influence. It
would be
and and by the way I told Apac I said look the analogy if the
NRA was supporting a bunch of politicians and cared about the
Second Amendment and you had politicians that vote to confiscate
people's guns and the NRA turned around and raised money for
the people who voted to confiscate guns. You know what? No one
would ever care what they said again. So you're making the case
that Apac is Exactly. Hold on. That's the whole Isn't that like
the point that Apac's paying for influence? Even though we're
Even though those people worked against them, they still want
that influence, right? They didn't just go, "Oh, we're going
to ally with the Republicans." They're like, "No, no, no. We
need this voice to be here. We need this voice to be supporting
both sides. It's not as powerful as people say it is." And I
completely agree with you. I've I've watched that and I'm not
I I'm not making the case that Apac is all powerful and they're
running everything and putting Floyd in the water. I'm not making
that case at all because that's not true. I'm only trying to
get to the question of what Apac is. And I don't think you're
being straightforward about it. APAC is lobbying on behalf of
the interests of a foreign country and they're not registered
and you're saying no that's not true. You're saying that they
don't coordinate with the Israeli government. I coordinate they
do they talk with them? I don't know what they do. I can but
why don't you care? Isn't it meaningful if a foreign government?
Hey I talk with with Israel all the time. I talk foreign countries
all the time. But the law is and a lot of people have been prosecuted
under this law that if you are lobbying on behalf of foreign
government you must register. That's it. It's really simple.
And I don't know why if I'm working for Malaysia or Qatar or
Belgium and I'm working on behalf of its government's interest
through a group of Americans who are representing the friendship
between those two nations, I have to register under the Foreign
Agent Registration Act. And if I don't, I can go to jail. People
have gone to jail, including people I know. So, I don't understand
why we don't just be honest. He's talking about uh he's literally
talking about Roger Stone and Paul Maniffort there. I'm I'm almost
positive that's who he's talking about. They're a lobbying on
behalf of foreign government. They're coordinating with the government.
You know that that's true. That is not only not true, that is
false. They're not coordinating with the Isra government. Do
you do do you know how Apac raises money for for elected officials?
Like what they do, like what the actual mechanics is? Yeah. I
mean, they go to people who are sympathetic to Israel and raise
money and then send it to candidates who agree with them. So,
so what they'll do is so I I here's what's going to happen here
and Ted will deny. Ted's going to just say what Tucker said with
like a totally different spin, but he's going to say mechanically
the exact same thing. Okay,
it's going to be the exact same. In my last election, Apac endorsed
me and they'll host a fundraiser and they'll host a fundraiser
in Dallas or Houston or Atlanta or New York or LA and they'll
do a fundraiser and they'll get someone who will host it and
it's usually a business owner, lawyer, doctor, someone who host
it. And you get typically at an AP pack fundraiser
uh 30 40 50 maybe 100 people who live in that city, right? Uh
who care about a strong US-Israel relationship.
Yeah, that's literally what Tucker said. You go to US citizens
who care about a strong who are sympathetic to Israel, care about
a strong USIsraeli relationship, and you raise money from them.
And Ted was like, "No, no, no, no. That's not how it works at
all. What they do is they set up a fundraiser and they find citizens
who are sympathetic to Israel and want a strong US-Israeli relationship
and they ask them to give you money, but they give you the money
directly and and if they have, you know, 50 people, each of them
writes $1,000 check and you raise $50,000. I've been to an AP
pack fund raise, right? I know what it looks like, but but that
is not an it's so how does Ted Cruz and again, how much it I
don't understand. Somebody has to be paying him, right, to make
such a ass of himself live on a stream. How the who is who is
paying him to do these absolutely moronic defenses
where he says, "No, no, no, Tucker. That thing you just said
totally wrong. Let me say the exact same thing." That's how it
actually works. Is it even money at this point? I don't know.
I feel like at this point he's saying these things so somebody
doesn't kill him. Yeah. At well, at this point, I'm like, can
we get uh I understand we're all really psyched to see if Elon
Musk or Trump are on the Epstein flight logs, but can I get a
Ted Cruz name check on there or whatever his name was before
this, Raphael Cruz? Is that guy on those Epstein flight logs?
Cuz what's going on here? How the is he doing this? Why is he
doing this? And by the way, there's no representative of the
Israeli government there. You have when you're in Dallas, you're
meeting with false and silly conversation. I know all this. I
know all this. The question is is are Apex goals shaped by the
goals of the Israeli government to any extent? Okay, that's a
really simple lobbying on behalf of it's a simple it's not it's
really not question it apex goals shaped by the goals of the
Israeli government and I'm just going to ask you a question straight
forwardly and if you say no I think we both know that's not true.
Hey are they shaped by is that are they coordinating with the
Israeli government? Are they talking? It's so painful. It's like
pulling teeth. Are they coordinating with the Israeli government?
Are they talking? Well, yeah. What are people not allowed to
talk in the in the age in the year of our Lord 2025? Are people
not allowed to talk? Is talking illegal, Tucker? Are you saying
talking is illegal? Like it's so embarrassing.
Israel directing them. What are you want to talk about? FAR,
the law on lobbying on behalf of someone. It is I hire you and
you lobby on behalf of me. I direct you. Does Israel direct Apac?
No, they are not lobbying on behalf of them. Do they care about
them? Yes. But do you think that it's just interesting because
what you're now where does that loophole work for anybody else
if China if there was a China lobby that was just the exact same
thing but it was transparently like negoti or uh communicating
with the the Chinese government only advocating for like policies
that were favorable for China
would that be allowed to be reg not registered as a foreign uh
entity?
The answer is just like no. I I don't there might be things that
exist like uh sort of parallel but I don't think they'd be as
effective is the issue. Anyway, also all of those other foreign
governments are just allowed you're allowed as a agent of the
Chinese government you are allowed to lobby. Yes, exactly Schumafine
but is there an American Chinese lobby that doesn't have FAR
oversight? That would be the question describing in a very defensive
way. I will say
because nobody's denying that you can lobby on behalf of the
Chinese government. Nobody's denying that. We're asking if that
if that is done. Okay. So, possibly I understand that this is
a Chinese lobby. Nobody foreign influence over our politics.
No. And you began and it's so transparently obvious to everybody.
I don't know why you would be embarrassed of it. You said that
you are sincerely for Israel. I believe you. I don't think you
have some weird agenda. You seem to By the way, by the way, Tucker,
it's a very weird thing. The obsession with Israel when we're
talking about foreign countries obsession. You're not talking
about Chinese. You're not talking about Japanese. You're not
talking about the Brits. You're not talking about the French.
the question. What about the What about the Jews? I'm an anti-semite
now. You're asking the question, Tucker. You're asking why does
he think he's talking to? Oh god.
My bad. If somebody is actually pulling the strings for Israel
and making stuff like this happen, this is creating so many anti-semitic
people, so many people who are like, "Why the [__]
is he doing this to himself? Why would he do why would he do
that?" Tucker pulled the anti-semite card. No, he didn't. What
do you think the card is Ted's pulling when he goes, "Oh, why
are people so why are you so obsessed with Israel, [__]
Why are you so obsessed with Israel? What are you doing over
there? Your Israel obsession. It's obvious what's happening."
Right? But like he they're honestly they push people in this
direction. There's no reason Ted should come to this interview
and be so pressed and so embarrassing and so incapable of answering
questions directly. It shouldn't happen. If even if everything
was above board there, it seems to me like Ted Cruz thinks he's
taking money from a foreign government to lobby for them. Like
he knows he's done something wrong and he is now in a flop sweat
trying to justify it without looking too bad. Anyway, the controlling
our foreign policy. That's what you just hardly saying that and
I have that is exactly what you just said. Well, actually, I
can speak for myself and tell you what I am saying. Good on behalf
not simply of myself, but on my many friends who would have the
same questions, which is to what extent, and I it's interesting
you're trying to derail my questions by calling me an anti-semite,
which you are. I did not. Of course you are. And and rather than
be honorable enough to say it right to my face, you are sitting
queasy feline way implying it or just asking questions about
the I'm asking questions about the just show us pictures of you
shaking hands with Holy
uh pass the test. Sherry, I was so wrong. Can I just say that
I was so wrong and that this is amazing content and it's it's
just awesome start to finish. This has been Well, there was the
little bit where he started yapping about the Cold War, but other
than that, this is awesome. Someone clipped that when he was
like, "Cherry, I was so wrong." I was so wrong. This is such
good content. I knew Ted Cruz was an idiot, but I thought he'd
be like at least a an idiot who didn't look like this
this like disorganized. Can't defend anything he's doing. Beline,
that's a way of saying feminine, by the way. His chin just disappeared.
Where's his neck? It's gone. It's all gone. There's nothing to
do with Judaism. It has to foreign government. Isn't Israel controlling
our foreign policy? That's not about the You said I'm actually
And by the way, you're the one that just called me I think a
sleazy feline. So let let's be clear. Sleazy to imply that I'm
an anti-semite, which you just did. No, I just said that.
You can't even admit what he did. We all see what you're doing.
Oh, it's so it's so scummy. This is It's actually We're getting
like insights into the H3 versus um versus stuff, right? Like
this is the thing. It's like I'm not saying I'm not saying you're
an anti-semite, but you seem curiously obsessed with Israel.
What's up? Who's who in this situation? Who's Ethan? Who's Hassan?
Well, Ted would be Ethan here. I'm just saying there's like uh
there's like a plausible deniability when you don't actually
say you're anti-semitic right now. Although Ethan, actually,
maybe it's not an insight because Ethan does just call everybody
an anti-semite, but it's just like, no, you are making allegations.
No, you are doing things and you're just trying to lie to me
about what's actually happening. Like, let's just be honest.
Let's let's dispense with the pageantry. Let's just be honest
about what's going on here. It's not even that it wouldn't even
be that bad. Like I'm fine supporting Israel. I just don't want
to be told that like nothing weird is happening. There's no special
treatment. There's nothing going on. No, no, no. Look the other
way or you're an anti-semite. When I hear that, I immediately
go, "Oh, wait. We should look back in this direction." That's
a That's a weird argument. That's a non-argument. What the [__]
are you saying over here? What's going on? Question you're asking.
You answer it. Give me another reason. If you're not an anti-semite,
give me another reason why the obsession is Israel. I am in no
sense obsessed with Israel. We are on the brink of war with Iran
and so these are valid questions.
If I can finish, you
asked me why I'm obsessed with Israel. 3 minutes after telling
me that when you first ran for Congress, you elucidated one of
your main goals, which is to defend Israel. And I'm the one who's
obsessed with Israel. I don't see a lawmaker's job as defending
the interest of a foreign government. Period. Any government,
including He really criticizing me. You're obsessed. Oh my god.
You're like obsessed. You've like responded to two of my my claims.
You're obsessed. God, I need the I need the Kyle Klinsky tweet.
Kyle the Kyle Klinsky Jim Jordan tweet. Hold on, I'll find it.
Ones that my ancestors come from. So that's my position. That
does not make me an anti-semite. And shame on you for suggesting
otherwise. And I mean that. And that's low. And you know it's
low. So why don't you just answer my questions for the way you
certainly have the IQ to do it. So, shame on you is is cute.
By the way, Tucker, it is it's not cute. I'm offended. You're
You're obsessed with the You just told me. You just called me
a sleazy feline. It is sleazy to imply that I'm an anti-semite
for asking questions about how my government is. You want to
count how many questions you asked about what about what about
Israel? What about AP? act about the I I have this is dude it's
like dude it's it's like we've been in Oz the entire time and
we've seen behind the curtain and none of it works anymore right
we we've seen behind the curtain we know that it's just a little
old man back there okay Oz you have no power you can't do anything
stop calling me an anti-semite I can see behind that curtain
okay stop it just stop it you're embarrassing yourself Ted nothing
to do with the whatever that means. This has to do with a foreign
government. And once again, shame on you for conflating the two.
They have nothing to do with each other. I'm talking about the
influence. The Israel have nothing to do with each other. All
Jews are an attack on all Jews, which I am not nor would I ever
be undertaking. Now, I'm not attacking anybody. By the way, that's
that's who who Iran wants to kill is all the and all the Americans.
And I'm totally opposed to that. Okay. But now because except
you don't want to do it just insane what aboutism. Ted Cruz will
do anything but answer two or three simple questions. Okay. He'll
throw out any allegation. He'll say Tucker hates America. Tucker
wants all Americans killed. Right. Tucker wants to support Iran.
The people want to kill all Americans and all Jews. Of course
he's an anti-semite.
Decisions need to be made. We can talk about those decisions
and I plan to. Good. But I just want to get a sense of whether
you think having described yourself as an America first person
whose only criterion for judgment on foreign policy is America's
national interest to what extent you're influenced by a foreign
government which gives you a lot of money through its lobby.
And you're claiming this has nothing to do with the foreign government.
They're not coordinating. Yes, they're spying on us but doesn't
bother you. And I'm sort of wondering like what is this? This
is the one of the weirdest conversations I've ever had. I'll
tell you it is a bizarre conversation. Uh also here the Jim Jordan
tweet right here. Oh wait, wait. That's the wrong thing. Uh,
not that one. That one.
We fly the American flag in America. Representative Jordan has
an Israeli flag outside of his office door. This is This is unironically
like a whole bunch of American politicians. And like it's just
funny that like
it sucks cuz I this means like this doesn't mean anything like
I'm okay with um with like people being anti-Semitic or like
I want you know people to live in fear. Nothing like that. But
it's like, dude, why? You can't you can't have these insane double
standards for behavior. You cannot call out all of these people
for flying Palestinian flags or Mexican flags at protests and
and then openly, happily wear Israeli flag pins when you're in
a pres presidential debate like Nikki Haley did, fly an Israeli
flag outside of your door like Jim Jordan does, right? You cannot
do this. You cannot have this double standard where you're like,
"Oh, it's totally treasonous to criticize America and do this."
But when you criticize Americans who actually have questions
about money going to Israel, you do so with an Israeli flag outside
of your office. You are the thing you accuse those people of
doing, right? You are that exact thing that you think they're
flying a Mexican flag because they stand with Mexico more than
America. You are that thing. You are doing that thing. It's just
projection. It's crazy. Anyway, and I'll answer any question
you like, but let's try to Are you going to call me an anti-semite
again or no? Let's try to ratchet down the temperature a little
bit. You're the one who went to motive. I'm asking honest questions.
I'm just asking questions. Yes, that's that is what I'm
Let's try to ratchet down the temperature a little bit.
Picture the house of your dreams. Maybe it's got an out. Let's
ratchet down the temperature. I'm getting a little too right
now. Can we Can you just You know, your hips are hitting my your
hips are thrusting way too hard, Tucker. I need you to bring
down the pressure a little bit. Okay. Bring it down, Tucker.
Sorry. I just Rhox is sending me memes in the background and
these are the things that come to my mind. Okay. Uped
up. It's It's gross. Gross. Gross. Gross. Distinguished gentleman.
Yeah. So, this great movie. It's actually a fun comedy uh about
politics. And Eddie Murphy in the movie is a con man who gets
elected to Cong. Uh yet again, we're getting a counterpoints
moment here. Okay. What is this irrelevant story? Why are you
telling me some stupid story when we actually had a material
disagreement and you would not answer my question and you've
gone, "Let's bring down the temperature. I'm going to tell you
a little story." Shut the up. Talk about something material.
Talk about something with substance. Please don't do this. Anything
but this. And he's literally a con man who the congressman dies.
He has the same name and so he runs and they get elected. And
there's a there's a scene in the movie where where Eddie Murphy
is a freshman member of the of Congress and he's sitting down
with a sleazy lobbyist
and uh he's asking the lobbyist, "All right, what should my positions
be on I think they were talking about power plants and and electrical
transmission lines and and the lobbyist like, well, what do you
believe?" And Nie Murphy's the comment said, "I don't care. Whatever
gets me the most money, I'll do whatever gets me the most money."
And the lobbyist says, "No, no, pick a side. Doesn't matter what
you pick. If you pick one side, we'll go shake down everyone
who supports that side and they'll give you money. If you pick
the other side, that's fine. We'll just go to the other side
and shake down that. That's a little bit the way it works. And
and you often get get leftists in the media who say, for example,
if you support the Second Amendment, as you do and I do, well,
you're just bought bought and paid for by the NRA. And that actually
is backwards. I believe in the Second Amendment because I believe
in the Constitution. Now, am I proud that the NRA supports me?
Sure. because people who care about the Second Amendment want
to support. Okay, so this is perfect, Ted. This is absolutely
perfect. Now, tell me where your support from Israel for Israel
comes from and why it's causing you to make decisions that weigh
it like a I guess favorably against American support. Right.
You're saying it's not to do with money. You're saying you just
He's not. I don't believe he is. He's Latino. Is his wife
Ted Cruz? Is Ted Cruz? Philly just hit $2. Israel big win. Iran
boo. Ted Cruz told me the Bible has to protect Israel. Lord Belelffort
big win. Revine change is my favorite. Okay. Thank you for the
donation. STV Philly. Uh you might need to put that in OBS to
make it work. I don't know why. For some reason it doesn't work
out in OBS for me. Oh, then control audio v OBS on the browser
source and then it should work just fine. Yeah, I did that. Oh,
then I literally don't know. Could try refreshing. Maybe I could
play it again if you want to try messing with some stuff. Hold
on. All right. Not yet. I'll let you know. Okay. Leaders who
fight for it, but it gets it backward. Look, Apac, when I ran
for the Senate, Apac didn't support me. I supported Israel before
they supported me. I'm I'm happy to have their support because
they share my objective. No, but you're missing I'm not suggesting
that you're bought and paid for. I'm not saying that. Actually,
I want to go back.
I want to go back and take the transcript because you just said
a minute ago, are you I'm slightly paraphrasing, but are you
are you lobbying for a foreign government because they pay you
a lot of money? That's basically what you said. So, you are suggesting
that. Let me let me just be clear about what I think. Your views
seem totally sincere. Yes. You take money from people who agree
with you. Yeah, I believe that. I take money from people who
disagree with me. I'm only trying to get to the question
of to what extent is the US government influenced by other governments?
And it's a lot. It's hardly just Israel. It's hardly just Israel.
I don't think Israel is the main one. There are lots of government.
Okay, now Tucker is just Israel.
Israel is one of the main ones. Tucker, come on. Israel is one
of the main ones is a massive influence on this city and it's
a huge as you know. I couldn't agree more and there are lots
of other the UK which is a truly sinister place in my opinion
as a ethnic Brit. I can say I think it's that's my view. Do it
now. Yes. Maybe you disagree. I think they're on the wrong path.
I I I love
But their government is without getting into that. I'm just saying
I don't think Israel's the only one, but it's the only one we're
instantly called.
Ted Cruz told me the Bible says to protect Israel. Okay. Belffort.
Big win. And it's also the only government that no one will ever
criticize. And I find criticize Israel every minute of every
day. Like the only government that people You just implied he
was anti-semite. People will not criticize Rashida Tal just calling
Benjamin Netanyahu a war criminal. Um, that's Ti. But no, I'm
You said no one will criticize. I'm talking about Republicans
that I would vote for, including you. And I'm saying, you know,
whatever. I I don't even like talking about Israel. Well, uh,
all Tucker has to do is go scoreboard and point to like the congressional
outlay of seats, okay, in the House and the Senate and say, "Which
one of these people, how many of these people criticize Israel?
Is it 2%? Is it 5%? I don't think it's above 5%." what I care
about. I never do because it's not worth being called anti-semmites
from AP pack recipients.
But now we're on the verge of joining a war
and I just want to be clear about why we're doing this. All right.
So, and and let's get into Iran momentarily, but but you suggested
it was a strange thing that I said a minute ago. Is the Israel
of the Bible the same as the current Israeli government ago that
when I came into the Senate I resolved that I was going to be
the leading defender of Israel and what you didn't ask is why.
So let me tell you why. No, you said I was obsessed with Israel
and you had just told me that like your driving motive to get
to the Senate was to defend Israel. I'm like I don't think I'm
the one who's obsessed with Oh, Ted's the full-on evangelical
package. Okay. He believes Israel is the the promised land that
it's required for like revelations, right? That's what he's going
to go through this whole thing. it's going to be a religious
motive for him. I would say I would say that's pretty suspicious,
too. But okay, that's to me that's just saying yes, I do think
Israel is like as important or or more important potentially
than America, right? If that's what you if that's your goal of
making it to the Senate, if you've said that, oh, it's to defend
Israel. I think you are not somebody who should be in politics.
I'm sorry. Get the [__] out. Tucker, words matter.
And you know that. I said I resolved to be the leading defender
of Israel. And you said your driving motive, the reason you're
in the Senate. You want to be the leading defender of Israel.
I would think if I ran for Senate, I'd be like, there are people
dying of drug IDs on the street. My driving motive is to fight
for Texas and America and to fight for jobs and to fight for
the Constitution. And And you played a very, very careful word
game of a li. You're the one who said it, not me. So, you still
haven't asked why, but I'm going to tell you why. Wait, what
do you mean? What is the What do you mean the why? Didn't Ted
What did Ted just say? You didn't ask me what. Hold on. I have
to go back now because Ted was like, "You never asked me why
it was so important for me to defend Israel." So, what did he
say? Let's get into Iran momentarily, but but you suggested it
was a strange thing that I said a minute ago that when I came
into the Senate, I resolved that I was going to be the leading
defender of Israel. And what you didn't ask is why. So, let me
tell you. Okay. He didn't say driving force. So, maybe maybe
he is good there. Okay. He didn't say driving force right there.
He said, "I'm going to be I just resolved to be the leading defender
of Israel." Now, in a body where basically everybody defends
Israel, that's a curious motivation. That's a curious like guiding
light. But okay, no, you said to get to the You're the one who
said it, not me. So, you still haven't asked why, but I'm going
to tell you why.
Okay. And the reason is twofold. Number one, as a Christian,
growing up in Sunday school, I was taught from the Bible, those
who bless Israel will be blessed, and those who curse Israel
will be cursed. And from my perspective, I want to be on the
blessing side of things. Oh, the those who bless the government
of Israel. Those who bless Israel is what it says. It doesn't
say the government of it. Says the nation of Israel. So that's
in the Bible. As a Christian, I believe that. Where is that?
I I can find it to you. I I don't have the the scripture off
the tip of my You pull out the phone and use the It's in Genesis.
But so you're quoting a a Bible phrase. You don't have context
for it and you don't know where in the Bible it is, but that's
like your theology. I'm confused.
What did that even mean? Tucker, I'm a Christian. I want to know
what you're talking about. Okay. Where does where does my support
for Israel come from? Number one, because biblically we are commanded
to support Israel. But number two, hold on.
Hold on. You're a senator and now you're throwing out theology
and I am a Christian. I am a God.
Why?
Why? I'm a Christian. I are biblically. Would it be good if um
if those Islamic extremists in Syria weren't all the Christians?
Want to know what you're talking about? H where does where does
my support for Israel come from? Number one, because biblically
we are commanded to support Israel. But number two, hold on.
No, hold on. Hold on. You're a senator and now you're throwing
out theology and I am a Christian and I am allowed to weigh in
on this. We are commanded as Christians support the government
of Israel. We are commanded to support Israel and we're
we're told those who bless Israel will be blessed. But what?
Hold on. Define Israel. This is important. Are you kidding? I
This This is a majority Christian country. Define Israel. Could
do you not know what Israel is? That would be the country you've
asked like define Israel as it's laid out in the Bible, idiot.
He's not saying what is the government of is No, he's saying
what does it mean to support Israel? What does that mean biblically?
You're doing theology theologically. Okay. What does it mean
to support Israel? What does it mean to bless Israel? 49 questions
about. So that's what Genesis ref that's what God is talking
about. The nation of Israel. Yes. The And so is that the current
borders, the current leadership? He's talking about the political
entity called Israel. He he's talking about the nation of Israel.
Yet nations exists and he is discussing a nation. A nation was
the people of Israel
the descendants of Abraham who in Genesis. Is that the same as
the country run by Benjamin Netanyahu right now? Yes. Yes, it
is. Okay. And by the way, it's not run by Benjamin Netanyahu
as a dictator. It's it's a democratic country that elected
the prime minister.
Ted is trying to grab any handle he can on this conversation
to like stop it and just drag it into the mud. He's looking to
be Andrew Wilson right now. Okay. He wants to get as pedantic
as he possibly can to stop this from moving any further forward.
He's just like he's just holding on for dear life. Let me shut
this down any way we can. But just just like you know America
is the country run by Donald Trump. No, actually the American
people elected Donald Trump. The same principle. This is silly.
I'm talking about the political entity of modern Israel. Yes.
And that is you believe that's what God was talking about in
Genesis. I do. But but that country has existed since when? Uh
for thousands of years. Now, there was a time when it didn't
exist and then was recreated just over seven years ago. But I'm
saying I think most people
that line in Genesis to refer to the people, God's chosen people.
That's not what it says. Okay. Israel, but you don't even know
where in the Bible it is. So, I I don't I don't remember the
scriptural citation, but okay. I keep it's like Genesis 16 or
something like that, but yes, it's in the earlier part of the
book. But the point is you keep interrupting me before I finish
my important to know what you're talking about. I don't know
what you're So you're saying as a Christian, if I believe in
Jesus, I have to support the modern state of Israel. I'm not
saying that you I'm explain that is literally what you're saying.
Yes. Wait, what is he saying? He's saying Israel in the in the
Bible in that in that exact scripture that Tucker quoted is the
modern day Israel and to bless you have to bless Israel. If you
bless Israel, you will be blessed. He's saying yes, you have
to support Israel. Christians are biblically he said biblically
commanded,
right? He said he literally said biblically commanded, did he
not right off the bat? Like biblically we are told to support
Israel. Explaining for me what my vote motivation is. But you
Okay, so I'm just trying to understand. You said God tells you
to support the modern state of Israel in the Bible. In some place
in the Bible that you heard about, but you don't know where it
is. That's your theology. You're going back. Am I a sleazy feline
again? I I mean, if you No. Why? What? He's accusing you of not
having any understanding. You haven't read the passage. You don't
know where it's from. You just heard it in some church and you
you just regurgitate it. And he's right. Anti-semitism. Again,
I will say that, but I don't think you will. try to be a little
less condescending. I'm trying to have a conversation. You're
throwing this stuff out and it's my job to figure out what you're
talking about and I don't understand. But you're not letting
me
Okay, I'm sorry. I want to be polite. That is for me a personal
motivation, but I also what I was about to say, I don't believe
my personal faith. Not everyone who I represent is a Christian.
It's not an argument for me to give that that we should do this
because of my faith. And so as as an elected official, I don't
give that as the reason we should support Israel. That is a personal
motivation for me, but but I don't think it is the reason we
should. The reason that I am the leading defender of Israel is
because Israel is our strongest ally in the Middle East, an incredibly
troubled part of the world, and supporting Israel benefits America.
And the I would just wonder, okay, um did what were Arab attitudes
towards America before World War II? Were were all of the Arabs
like in the Ottoman Empire and stuff? Were they like when America
was a you know a country that was founded and growing and becoming
like an international superpower? Were they all like death to
America or is there a lot of American support for Israel over
years and years and years that has led to that region being like
yeah death to America this country? Yeah, kind of. What do you
mean? Yeah, kind of. I'm I'm curious where that came from because
to me it's like I can see how a lot of interventions came about
as a result of supporting Israel after what the ' 60s7s but I
have no idea. I have no idea how the actual Arabs felt before
World War II.
Clearest illustration of that is what is happening right now.
Let me just make this point and then I don't know. They probably
still wouldn't like the society that America is with all the
haram. Well, they wouldn't like it now. They might say that now,
but America was a lot more conservative in 1950, right? And then
I'll just ask what you mean. That's it. Yeah. Look, Iran, I think
the most acute national security threat facing America right
now
is the threat of a nuclear Iran. I think China is the biggest
long-term threat, but
why? Where is this coming from? Who who are you citing to say
that they have any nuclear capability? And what what about that
nuclear capability is threatening the United States? Cute and
near-term is a nuclear Iran. Okay. And I think Israel is doing
a massive favor to America right now by trying to take out Iran's
nuclear capacity. And the reason I view Iran differently, we
talked before about Iraq. I oppose the the Iraq war. We talked
about Syria. I oppose military intervention in Syria. The reason
for that is those did not pose a threat to the United States.
I think Iran is marketkedly different. Number one, the Ayatollah
is a religious zealot. Zealot. He He is a lunatic, but but a
particularly dangerous kind of lunatic because he's driven You
just said you wanted to be Israel's number one defender because
the Bible commanded you to do so.
Why? Why are you throwing stones right now, Ted? By religious
fervor when he says death to America and death to Israel, I believe
him. And I think Iran is trying to get a nuclear weapon because
there there is a very real possibility they would use a nuclear
weapon. So, you want to ask, how does supporting Israel benefit
us? Right now, this tiny little country the size of the state
of New Jersey is fighting our enemies for us and and taking out
their top military leadership and and trying to take out their
nuclear capacity. That makes America much safer.
Why?
How? And why do you believe do you have any indication that Iran
has the ability to launch a nuclear strike, an effective nuclear
strike at America? Do you believe Iran has the capability to
launch a nuclear strike at all? Do you believe that like where
is the threat to America? So, um the president Iran cannot have
a nuclear weapon and he will do whatever it takes to stop Iran
from getting a nuclear weapon. He said that like a hundred times.
He clearly means it. I think he will use force to affect that
if he feels he has to. I think he's been really clear about that.
I don't know, but it seems that way. Do Do you feel that? Do
you think that's correct? um whether he would use force to stop
a nuclear weapon, I think he he has put that option on the table.
He certainly suggested I mean I have literally no idea what's
going to happen, but just reading his statements um he's made
that really clear. So what he has been very clear about and I
I spoke with the president on Sunday is he has been very clear
to Iran that if they attack US service men and women, there will
be real consequences and and and I think very serious military.
By the way, this is a sidebar, but I just can't resist. The prime
minister of Israel said that Iran tried to Donald Trump twice.
Yeah, I I read your newsletter this morning and and but do you
believe that's true? Again, I think it was sort of a word game.
What is true is Iran is trying to Donald J. Trump and they have
hired hitman. Now, you pointed out No, he said that they tried
have tried twice to kill him and I I don't know that I don't
have any evidence that's true, but I sort of wonder if that is
true, why aren't we at war with them already? Okay. And I read
we were made we were made aware of that like four or five years
ago. Oh, I thought No, it was during the election. I thought
thought it was during this election that we became aware of it.
I thought it was during the first election with Biden.
Was it? I don't recall that. Maybe. You could be right. I don't
remember that. I remember this one like this year a couple months
ago. Oh, I'll look it up. But yeah, I might be that was the second
time. Maybe it was the second time. Maybe they did right after
the silly mounty thing. Some people are pointing out that Trump
did try to their big or sorry, he did add their general, right,
Cassim Zolammani. So they might have gone after him after that.
Okay, it could be the second time. This could have been the second
your newsletter this morning and I thought it was
it was playing word games to to draw a political point. How's
that a word game? It's my president and Can I tell you? Yeah,
please. Okay. You rightly pointed out there's no evidence that
this clown in Butler, Pennsylvania, who shot the president was
working for the Iranians. I don't think he was. There's no evidence
of that. Um although I would like to know more about who he was
and what's going on, but but I don't find it plausible that he
was working for the Iranians. So, was that caused by the Iranians?
No. But what is true and what your newsletter didn't acknowledge,
is it true or false that Iran is currently trying to murder Donald
J. Trump? No, you're right. It came up in September 25th, 2024.
Okay. Um, but not just that, those were the threats. I think
a couple months later, there's alleged like an Iran has a hit
list of former Trump aids. So, our Secret Service or our feds
were like looking to protect multiple people, not just Trump.
Okay. Which you would say is concerning, right? If these are
people who work for Trump, it these are all people with security
clearance in some way, shape, or form. Uh, yeah. And I mean,
just in general, like menacing the employees of the US president
would be bad. menacing Americans like targeting Americans directly
as a state would be something America should probably care about.
Yeah, I would say like obviously. So, yeah. Crazy. Okay, I'm
gonna hit play on this. I'm gonna get a drink and use the bathroom.
I'll be right back. I need some more water. Okay, Trump and his
paid hitmen to do so. Well, that's that's the question. And I
don't know the Butler, Pennsylvania thing. Just put that aside.
I don't know. So So miss poke when he said those two assassinations
were because of Iran. But what he was saying that is right is
they're actively trying to murder Donald Trump. Is there Okay,
so you're aware of a plot to kill Trump. Yes. That Iran is paying
for. And by the way, when when uh it it has been over the last
I'd say 18 months to two years in the United States. In the United
States, yes, they they and and let me point out, has anyone been
arrested? Uh for the Trump attempted assassination? No. But they
are also actively paying Iranian hitmen to murder Mike Pompeo
when he was President Trump's first secretary of state, the first
term rather. Uh John Bolton when John Bolton was national security
adviser to President Trump. Uh and a guy named Brian Hook who
was assistant secretary of state right during the Biden administ
when no one has been arrested for these assassination attempts
on Trump. Um yes they've hired hitmen. How do we know that? All
right, let me let me break it down. People have been arrested.
So, the reason I brought up Pompeo, Bolton, and Hook, who are
under active assassination attempts because of their service
of the first Trump administration
under the Biden Well, they say that. I've never seen any evidence
of it. Can I give you the evidence? Well, let's just stick with
Trump. No, no, no. Because these are interrelated. So, so let
me make a bloody point. Under the Biden administration, the State
Department was spending $2 million a month providing security
for Pompeo, Bolton, and Hook. And they did arrest Iranian hitmen,
okay, at John Bolton's apartment complex who rented, I think,
the apartment next to him and were actively trying to Oh, well,
this is something, right? This is something. This is like way
better.
But, uh, Ted Ted's like trying to put it together now. Now, I
will say here's the thing. Okay, here's the thing. Linking you
a political argument. I'm political article that I think explains
this better. Oh, sure. I would say the funny thing here is is
Trump had just Trump did. Okay. If that first administration
did kill an Iranian general,
um
if if that wasn't enough for like if that wasn't is it really
that insane that they try to come back in any way or is it just
like oh that's an active war. We have to go after them now. That
they're attacking low-level functionaries from the US government
in retaliation. I don't know. Yeah. It says Iran has been openly
threatening Trump and those who oversaw his national security
strategy since January 2020 when Trump ordered a drone strike
from Solommani.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, they've just been threatening him the whole
time. Okay. Um, do you think that was enough of the summary or
do you think I should read the article as well? I see the article.
I didn't look at the rest of it. It just seems like it's it's
saying everything that we already are talking about. Yeah. Yeah.
Mr. Solommani. Um every person that was um involved with Trump's
national security strategy. That's what it said in that paragraph
above it. Okay. Yeah. So that makes sense. John Bolton, um Mike
Pompeo,
Trump himself, all these people. Again, they did kind of bomb
as we reported. They did kind of literally bomb
an Iranian general. Okay, here's a the Department of Justice
has charged an Iranian with trying to former national security
adviser John Bolton. US officials say the man was a member more
confirmation, but thank you. Thank you uh Dark Panda for the
link, Cherry for the link. Okay, so Ted's Ted's being real right
now. He's being real and they went and arrested them. So yes,
they caught Iranian hitman. Now, it so happens Iran's not very
good at it. Uh and so they but they are actively trying and in
fact what about Trump? He's the president. If there's an applot
to Trump by the Iranians. Okay. So you dispute that the Iranians
are trying to kill Trump. Of course. I mean that's the most important
question. The prime minister of Israel just said there have been
two assassination attempts against Donald Trump by the Iranians.
And I think it's a very fair question. Maybe you disagree to
ask what are you talking about? Okay. And and and I agree with
you that he misspoke. So, there weren't those two attempts? There
were two attempts, but the the clown in Butler, Pennsylvania,
and the other guy on the golf course were not connected to the
Iranian. Wait, wait, what was Netanyahu saying? Hold on. Netanyahu
claimed two attempts on Trump's life and then said, "We have
to respond to Iran because of this." And he's going to say that
it was the two assassination attempts from the from the campaign
trail, the guy in the golf course and the guy in Butler, Pennsylvania,
the kid. That's insane.
That's the part that that he misspoke. But by the way, when you
speak all the time occasion, what he said that was accurate is
that Iran is actively trying to murder Donald J. Trump and his
paid hitman. Okay. But right and he was playing it with the with
the two. I understand. I understand. But I just want to pull
that thread because it's so important. I voted for
Okay. I don't know if this is here.
Can we go Mr. Vidia? Oh, is this not
I thought there'd be a video here of him saying it. What the
hell? Okay,
American people for launching attacks on Iran. Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu makes a bombshell claim that Iran
was behind President Trump's assassination attempts. Can I get
a quote? These are the pe these people who chant death to America
tried to President Trump twice, Netanyahu said as he was making
his case to the American people for launching attacks on Iran
amid the Islamic Republic and Israel's deadly exchange of missiles
over the weekend. Do you want these people to have nuclear weapons
and the means to deliver them to your cities? Of course not.
So, we're defending ourselves, but we're also defending the world.
Ted is literally just saying the exact same things that Netanyahu
is saying. Dude, Ted's Ted's out of his mind. Ted's out of mind.
Donald Trump campaign for Donald Trump. He's our president and
we're on the cusp of a war. So, if Iran is it a misspeak when
BB says something intentionally untrue knowing that for some
reason all these Apac funded politicians will repeat it? Is that
a mistake? Doesn't seem like it'd be a mistake. There's evidence
that Iran paid hitmen to kill Donald Trump and is currently doing
that. Where is that? Like, what are you even talking? I've never
heard that before. You Okay, BB didn't say it. Baby just said
it. We just read a quote from BB Netanyahu of him saying it.
Where is the evidence? Who are these people? Why haven't they
been arrested? 24. Check DMs. There's the video. Play this clip
here. Oh no. I hate this guy. I hate being on his side and something.
Hold on. Let me let me turn the volume up. Not PVD.
You just said u Iran project President Trump twice. Do you have
intel that the assassination attempts on President Trump were
directly from Iran? Through proxies? Yes. Through uh through
their intel. Yes. They wanted
the answer through proxies. What was the answer? Through proxies.
Through proxies. Yes. Through their intel. Yes. You didn't say
yes. We have it. Because if you got the intel, give it to me
if I'm US. Play this clip here. I now that's okay. Maybe maybe
Netanyahu did misunderstand what Brett Barer was saying. Brett
Barer was definitely trying to ask, "Are you sure that the two
attempts on President Trump's life were because of Iran?" And
he said, "Yes, he could be referring to two different ones."
Maybe you want to be super charitable. Maybe. Why are we not?
Never mind. Okay. Sorry. At war with Iran. That's a great question
to ask. How do you know that that's true? We know that it's true
because we have been told that by the military and our intelligence
community for the last two years. We meaning who? Congress has
in the public. I mean, this was about where the evidence if there's
evidence for Donald Trump, he's our president and we're on the
cusp of a war. So, if Iran if there's evidence that Iran killed
Donald Trump and is currently doing that, okay, where is that?
Like, what are you even talking? I've never heard that before.
Okay. Where is the evidence? Who are these people? Why haven't
they been arrested? Why are we not at war with Now, I do believe
that during the 2024 election, there was an FBI press release
or something from uh like US intel that said Iran was trying
had tried to the president. Yes. But they were very clear in
that there was no um foreign connections with what the shooting
at the rally in Pennsylvania or with what happened in Florida.
There's like um an American in briefing. I have there's like
an NPR transcript I'll link to you if you want to see that. Okay.
Um yeah, I think that's definitely that's what I remember as
well is that it was unrelated. Yeah, I see the full video STV
Philly. I I'm just pretty confident that Netanyahu he he can
claim that he misspoke there. I don't think he misspoke, but
he can claim it. So that's a great question to ask. How do you
know that that's true? We know that it's true because we have
been told that by the military and our intelligence community
for the last two years. We meaning who? Congress has and the
public. I mean, we had multiple testimonies. I can send you uh
testims of the people or where this happened or what they tried
to do to Trump. We do not we have not apprehended an Iranian
hitman trying to kill him. We know that Iran is trying to do
so in the United States. Yes. And and by the way, like Iran put
out just seems like a huge headline and you're acting like everyone
knows this. I didn't know that. Iran put
um it couldn't have gotten very far because I don't believe there
was any kind of actual No, this was this was there was a press
release about this. Huge. It was a huge headline, but it's not
going to reach further than the actual assassination attempts.
That's the problem. Yeah, exactly. Cuz I think Trump I think
Trump spoke on it, right? I think Trump literally said like I
think he talked about Iran trying to kill him during the election.
Yeah, but unfortunately that intel comes after he was already
shot at twice. Oh yeah, because wasn't this a whole thing that
like that intel came after and then that that like triple underscored
for Trump? Like why the didn't I have better security, right?
Like how the did some random pimplyfaced kid take a shot at me
when now I'm finding out Iran's been trying to take a shot at
me? I think that's was the rhetoric during the election. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Sorry, I'm not yelling at you, Chair. I'm just in
general. Especially because um I mean it also came up because
he wasn't president at the time, right? He was like a retired
president. Not he was the previous president. Biden was like
the current sitting Biden was the current sitting president.
So he almost tried to imply as if um they're like cutting the
budget for his Yes. That's what he tried to imply. Yep. Yeah.
They don't have to beat me in election if they can just let me
get popped. Yeah, exactly. About a whole video about murdering
Trump, right? But I've never heard evidence that there are hitmen
in the United States, I mean, trying to kill Trump right now.
We should like have a nationwide drag net on this and we should
attack Iran immediately if that's true. Don't you think? No.
Uh, so that would be why it wouldn't have been quite as bad as
I think when this was happening, Trump was not president. Now,
it's really bad that it's a sitting president, but sorry, that's
a what do you call it? Like a former president. It's still really
bad, but like I do believe when they were trying to kill him,
he was not president. But they're trying to president. They have
been for two years. They are enemy. They have been for two years.
Wait, was Trump president two years ago? I forget. Ted, you tell
me. I forget. Was Trump president two years ago?
What are you doing? We are trying to Why don't we just nuke Tron
if they're trying to murder our president? There's nothing that
you could do that would be worse for the United States than murdering
Trump. And I just don't understand why you're not calling for
the use of nuclear weapons against the ayatollah right now. I'm
serious. If they if you really believe they're trying to murder
of nuclear weapons part of the problem of So you mean you don't
seem to take the allegations seriously. I do. If you believe
they're trying to murder Trump, we need to stop what we're doing.
Why can't you just do drones? Like Yeah. I think you make it
goofy when you jump all the way to the option that would what?
Destroy the planet and nuking Iran. Um, yeah, obviously they
wouldn't do that. He's I I think he's he's being as hyperbolic
as he can. He's saying he's trying to say there's no response.
Unserious. Yeah, he does make it unserious. The idea like he
could say he's trying to make it seem like the gap is bigger
between what should happen and what has happened, right? And
but he's saying he's going so hyperbolic that he's Yeah. now
just being goofy on his own and punish them. C can I ask something
and I mean this sincerely. So, all right. 20 years ago, you were,
I think it's fair to say, in the interventionist world. You were
a vote. You were a vocal defender of the Iraq war. I was a promoter
of the Iraq war. And you now, and I, that goes crazy as a soundbite.
I was a promoter of the Iraq war. Look, I think you think you
were mistaken. I think you were mistaken. That's okay. Look,
people change and learn and that's that's part of the journey
of being human. Your views have moved though. In my view, they
gone way too far the other end. And and and so I'm totally confused.
I'm saying, hold on.
This is one of the weirdest conversations I've ever had. I'm
saying if it's true that Iran is trying to murder Trump, we need
to move militarily against Iran immediately. That's not isolationism.
That's the most that's a cult of violence, which I am calling
for. If we believe that Iran is trying to murder our president,
we need to strike Iran. Okay. But then you say things like, "Well,
then just nuke which is what you just said. Just kind of a wait
what can what is happening? Isolationists say things like just
nuke them. What? Famous isolationist statement. Nuke that other
country. I'm an isolationist. Nuke them. Nuke them now because
I'm upset because I'm taking you seriously. You don't take your
own statements. I take my statements very serious. So I've asked
you where's the evidence this is true and you said well they're
trying to Brian Hook or something. Oh, which I'm against by the
way. I'm against hurting any American period. No matter. Dude,
you dispute that they're trying to murder
in Bolton. I'm not disputing.
Make Ted makes a positive claim. Doctor says, "Yo, can you show
me that information?" And he goes, "Wait, so you're saying they
didn't try to do this?" No, I'm saying you haven't shown me that
this did happen. They literally arrested the hitman with B. I'm
not I don't know why that's even relevant. I'm asking about the
president of the United States. Wait, it it's not relevant that
Iran hired hitmen to murder cabinet members in Trump's administration.
That doesn't go to
credible is it that they're willing to spend money to do opposed
to that. It's awful.
I am against anybody actually and especially foreign government.
I'm asking about your allegation and the prime minister of Israel's
allegation that
Iran is trying to kill terrorists is a good thing. People are
trying to murder Americans. Dude, it's so sad. What? Ted Cruz
I swear to God Ted Cruz used to have a brain. Why would he take
this interview? Do you think Tucker just lied about what the
interview was about? How did he end up here? How did he end up
here so unprepared to just get like this? What? What is happening
when uh when he originally ran for president, he would probably
he if in a civility politics world, Ted Cruz probably wins that
primary and becomes president.
Unironically,
I'm not joking. I think he wins that primary and becomes president.
In a Trump politics, I'm rewriting everything and actually your
wife's fat. You Ted in that world? Yeah, he gets totally decimated.
His career ends. Well, his career becomes far more embarrassing.
I'm sorry. It I think he was the most charismatic person. He's
the best speaker there. But the problem is he does these long
pauses. He does these like personal stories. They can be funny
if nobody points out that he's a bloiating [__] while
he does it. And Trump would just do that every time, right? Ted
would start yapping and Trump would just have some quippy oneliner
and then Ted would like lose his train of thought. It'd be over.
This is a good thing because if you're America first, you want
to protect America. And so taking out Osama bin Laden was a fantastic.
But you don't really believe that they're trying to murder Trump
or you. Yes, I do. Then why aren't you calling for military action
against tan right now? Because they're not very effective in
terms of hitmen. Their hitmen are not very effective. I do think
so. They're hitmen but not the bad kind, the efficient kind.
thing. They're a weak country who is on its knees and I think
we need to then why are we so afraid of them? Why are they the
biggest threat if they're a weak country that's on its knees?
Ted just lost so badly. That was Ted's number one thing. Actually,
Iran is the greatest acute threat to anybody. I think he says
a nuclear Iran, by the way, which I also just smuggled the entire
point in. Chris Christie was a better candidate. Chris Christie
is too fat to be president.
I'm sorry, evil Johnny Bravo. You don't have to be skinny to
be president. Obviously, Trump became president. Chris Christie
was just too fat to be president. Okay. Unfortunately, you get
some wide shots of him thrown in, he would have lost to Hillary
100%. I'm sorry. It would have happened. It would have happened
because they're trying. I'm trying to keep track. They're Yes.
Ompic being discovered 10 years earlier and uh and Chris Christie
being skinny. He would have been a two-term president. Skinny
Chris Christie could have been a two-term president 100%. Easy.
Trying to develop. Be a little less snarky. I know. You're right.
That is a problem that I have. I'm sorry. You just got demolished.
He gets absolutely destroyed. Be a little less snarky, Tucker.
What are you doing? Thank you, Tucker. They're trying to develop
nuclear weapons. They're closer. Wait, hold on. I just saw a
nuclear bomb in my chat. Chris Christie got ga had gastric bypass.
When don't don't look up this this is actually very common. There
are a lot of people who will get the surgery and it does not
help when
they're trying to develop nuclear weapons. They are close to
developing nuclear weapons and even a weak comp country with
a nuclear weapon. Look, I believe there is a very real possibility
if the Ayatollah develops a nuclear weapon that he would detonate
it either in Tel Aviv or New York or Los Angeles. See, this is
where you know he's totally foolish. How the is the Ayatollah
getting a a nuclear payload, a nuclear warhead to New York or
Los Angeles? And how is he doing it without American or Israeli
ears hearing about it at all? If if if
Iran actually had a nuclear payload and they loaded that up onto
a warhead that was capable of reaching the United States, every
missile site in Iran would evaporate in an instant. No chance.
And that would be utterly catastrophic. And I don't know what
the chances are of that. Let me zero zero. The chances are zero.
Comparing for Tel Aviv, it's not zero for I don't I don't even
think it's crazy for Israel to be super um vigilant against a
nuclear Iran, right? But for Los Angeles or New York City, the
chances contrast Iran to North Korea. Wait, can I just ask one
last question about trying to president? You sincerely believe
you promise that right now the Iranian government is trying to
murder our president. You sincerely believe right now. Absolutely.
And yet you are not calling for military action against the government
that's trying to murder our president. Can you explain that?
Uh I don't think they're very effective. I do think we should.
By the way, America is You're willing to take that risk? I think
we should protect the president and we should take I this is
just a really dumb thought because to for starters, okay, you
could say they're not effective. Yeah, they're not effective,
but they also don't have nuclear weapons. They're they're a country
you can strike with like uh total impunity, right? Total impunity.
So there's no there's no real downside for America in making
it clear, hey, if you try to our president, you're going to get
decimated for it. Take out our enemies. Well, Israel is doing
that right now. But aren't they why would we
the question was why for regime change? That's a pretty good
example of why I'm for regime change. Okay. So, you're saying
we should just go in and take out the government of Iran. Why
would we outsource it to Israel if they're trying to murder a
president? Okay. You you sound like the isolationist.
What I'm saying on any military judgment is there needs to be
a costbenefit analysis of what are the risks versus what are
the what are the uh what are the benefits. In this instance,
yeah, I think it is enormously in America's interest to do what
Israel is doing right now. Take out Iran's senior military leadership
and take out their nuclear capacity.
That is benefiting America and it is a good riskreward. I would
oppose invading Iran
and putting boots on the ground to topple the government. Uh
if the risk got severe enough, I would support that. But I think
the relative risk is not severe enough to justify that step at
this time. What I would absolutely oppose under any circumstances
is invading Iran and then staying and trying to turn them into
a democracy. And part of where Iraq really went off off the rails
is not only did we topple someone who was fighting radical Islamic
terrorists who's a bad guy, but then we tried the vision of interventionists,
it actually overlaps with the vision of a lot of Democrats. Let's
go promote democracy. Um, sure, evil Johnny Bravo. That that
could be true. But then you're like trying to smuggle a nuclear
warhead over ground through all of like across the Atlantic.
That that seems pretty difficult, right? I I feel like that would
be pretty difficult. I don't Yeah, I don't know.
Pretty hard. It is our military's job to kill the bad guys, to
defend America. In any case, we have no the IAEA and American
intel as of March said there is no indication that Iran is trying
to build a nuclear weapon. So, it's not their job to defend international
norms. It's not their job. So, I have zero desire for the US
military to turn Iran into Switzerland. Look, would it be nice
if they suddenly became Switzerland? Sure. If I could wave a
magic wand, great. But I'm not going to send your kids or my
kids to be in front of guns to go make that happen. Well, bless
you for that. I I think that's a that is the lesson that I learned
from Iraq. I promoted that war apparently unlike you. Um I was
dumber and and I think that you just articulated the main lesson
of it which is it's hard to do that and we're not good at it.
But but but I will and so we are agreeing on that. I will say
as a sorry I'm like looking at the time stamps coming up. There's
a whole section are Iranian assassins trying to
as a correlary
that doesn't mean that that horrible evil dictators are okay.
And going back to Reagan in the Cold War, we have lots of weapons.
I I am happy to highlight the brutality, the oppression, the
human rights abuses of regimes, even though I don't want to invade
them. I don't know what this is. First squawk. Is this a big
375,000
US officials prepare? Oh, s sourcing Bloomberg. US officials
prepare for strike on Iran in the coming days because I think
the bully pulpit of American leadership is really powerful and
and I think dictatorships are terrified. So I've spent 13 years
in the Senate. One of the things I do frequently is highlight
dissident in Iran, in North Korea, in China, in Venezuela, people
are being tortured. Miriam Ibrahim in in Sudan who who was sentenced
I don't care released early. And I hope that I Oh wow. I agree.
I I agree with you about it. What happens next in Iran? Next
question. And oh, true. Uh, guys,
what's up? Yeah, I was also going to say we should probably hit
our sub goals, but I would also like to stream longer. Yeah.
Uh, wait, hold on. We have we not hit Oh, we're 16 minutes away.
I didn't realize how far in the stream we've gone. Uh, we're
not that far away, guys. I think we're um we've got I think 20
bucks from the other thing. So, we're like four subs away from
another hour on the stream, right? We have a whole bunch from
Kickbot from earlier in the stream. So, guys, we're like four
subs away from another hour on the stream. Oh, sorry. Two more
hours on the stream. That is not another hour. That is two more
hours on the stream. Five subs. Five subs away from another two
hours on the stream. So, if you like the content, you guys can
sub through kick. You can you can donate. Okay. All of the audio
is fixed. So, now when you TTS through Kickbot or through Streamlabs,
that audio will come through crystal clear for me. Okay? Come
through crystal clear for the stream. So, if you guys want to
test that out, $2 TTS through Kickbot, all the AI TTS voices.
I'm cutting Cherry Oram speaking. What's up, Jerry? No, we got
to tell them how to how to TTS, how to donate. I think we should
do a 24-hour stream. We've got like Tom Tent later.
We have Maybe we can even live react to Tommy C. factecking Chudlo
Logic. I don't Yeah, I don't know if that's happening tonight,
but there is that entire Chudlo Logic like fact check stream
on on Tommy C. What else is there? I've got that kidology video
that I kind of wanted to check out. What else do we got? We got
I don't know if we've ever gotten highlights from Chris Bus.
Oh, yeah. I don't know. Well, I don't know if we've got any of
that either, but there's like there's lots of stuff. We could
make all kinds of stuff happen. We can go all kinds of longer,
but we do need guys some subs. Okay, we need five subs to get
another two hours on the stream. We're really close. So, if you
like the content, go ahead, sub, donate, okay? Join the Patreon.
patreon.com/jdk.
If we were to end early tonight by any means, I do not think
we'll be ending in like 15 minutes, but if we were to end pretty
early, okay, we've always got
Oiler calls. We are back to Oiler calls very soon. Um, I think
this is when we do NE Crisp is over in an Oiler call. Okay, you
guys want to do not airate crisp lettuce with us? I think oiler
call would be the place to do it. Threaten an oiler call. Get
ready to get donuts to extend stream. Well, I'm just going to
keep streaming for like a I think I'm probably going to keep
streaming. So, what amount of subs do we need for a 24-hour stream?
Uh, I forget. Quite a bit. Okay. I think Cherry said 1,000 bucks,
but we'll see. Anyway,
uh, yeah, donate, guys. Donate. What are you doing? Donate. Donate.
Donate. Donate. Donate. Donate. Okay, we're getting back to this.
We're getting through this. And we will go through all of the,
uh, we'll get through all the other stuff as well. There's I
think Tom Foolery debated Dean Withers on some. And then what
else is there? There's that Kidology video. Like I said, there's
the entire Chudlo Logic stream. Chudlogic versus Tommy C. That
is that is a lot. I don't know if I'm going to do it. Okay. By
asking you, we're I'm enjoying the Tucker content right now,
though. The Tuck tent. Okay. We're going to keep doing it. Specifically
about what's going to happen next in Iran and what should happen
next. So, you've he looks like a Tucker called for regime change.
You said you don't favor the US military participating in any
kind of regime change. You said you don't think, and bless you
for saying this, that the US military should try and turn it
into Belgium. Yeah, thank God. Um, but there is a third option
where it turns into Syria where it's this open wound and it causes
massive migration and further destroys Europe as Syria has and
that's a huge cost and where lots of people die and religious
minorities get murdered in Syria again. Are you worried about
that? Sure. And and listen that lots of bad things can happen
but going back to what we talked about the principle of defending
America. I agree with President Trump that Iran with a nuclear
weapon is an unacceptable risk to America and we need to stop
it. I agree with President Trump and and I'll but they don't
have they're not close to a nuclear weapon. There's no evidence
they're close to a nuclear weapon. I'll make a point, but he's
not for regime change. Don't have that as So, he and I disagree.
Look, I think he thinks it would be better. He has not said he's
for it. Um, and you know what? Look, it is consequential when
the president of the United States says, "I'm for regime change."
So, I understand why he hasn't. Uh, what he has said is he's
drawn a red line and said Iran No, you wait. He has said he's
for regime change. When is this from? 8 hours ago. When you say
unconditional surrender, that means regime change. I'm sorry.
Unconditional surrender is you literally put your country on
our hands. Your your government there's never been an unconditional
surrender where the existing government just stays on. Is there
has there? That seems crazy.
Will not have a nuclear weapon and and the only acceptable outcome
is complete dismantlement. They have centrifuges. They're enriching
uranium right now. They're trying to develop a nuclear weapon.
He said they they must have complete dismantlement. I led 52
senators, Republican senators, in a letter where we said, "We
agree with President Trump. That's the red line, complete dismantlement."
Uh, I agree with President Trump. I agree with him supporting
Israel taking out Iran's military leadership taking out their
nuclear capability. And I'll point out, look, if you look the
first term, I am hardressed to think of a single foreign policy
decision Donald Trump made the first term that I disagree with.
And and that's not entirely accidental because I spent a lot
of time the first term in the Oval Office with him. And what
happened in the first term often is you would have in the administration,
you had interventionists in the administration, you had isolationist
Uh oh. Gentle whale comes in with the 10 gifted. Keeping the
stream alive. Keeping the dream alive. All right, we got 50 and
55 10. So 65 on there. We'll take 60 off. We'll leave five on
for the next one. Gentlewell, thank you so much for the 10 gifted
extra two hours on the stream. 2 hours 11 minutes. Let's go.
And I will reset the meters. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
And they disagree. They would fight within the administration.
And often what it would give is an opportunity for me to come
in and say, "Hey, there's a middle path here that President Trump
agreed with frequently." And and it's worth noting in the first
term, he most assuredly was not an isolationist. Look, he took
out General Solommani, which I emphatically agree with. And in
fact, I introduced a resolution that we voted on the Senate floor
commending him for taking out General Solommani, who was the
leader of the IRGC and who was responsible for killing over 600
American servicemen and women. Uh when Trump came in, ISIS had
a caliphate that had grown up under Obama that was about the
size. Uh yeah, meters are reset, guys. We need 65 for the next
two hours. To add two more hours, we need 65. Okay, gentle. Well,
thank you so much for that 50 for the the 10 big ones
and we're ready to go with the rest of this. Okay, now he's about
to argue that Trump was not um was not an isolationist. He kind
of wasn't. He kind of did support wars, but then he got criticized
for that. And then he campaigned based on his old message. She's
done it a couple different cases. When Donald Trump called Kim
Jong-un little man and threatened fire and fury over Twitter,
Ted Cruz approved of that, I guess. Rocket Man.
Rocket Man. Yeah, not little man. Rocket man. Little Rocket Man.
Eyes of the state of Indiana. And Trump came in and utterly decimated
them. He killed the terrorists, took away their caliphate and
defeated them. And he also took out Baghdaddy, the head of ISIS.
I mean, those are not the actions of an isol. Wait, King Gedra
is not arguing that uh the emperor stayed in power after the
the war, is he? The emperor retained his ceremonial position.
The emperor is not the leader of Japan after World War II. They
had like a democracy after World War II. The emperor retained
like a ceremonial position, but he was no longer the emperor
of Japan.
But at the same time, I don't even know what isolation is. It's
just a slur designed to control. I mean, I don't never met an
isolationist. I don't even know what that mean. Okay. Rand Paul
is my colleague. ran as an isolation and Tucker, you've become
one, and I don't mean it as a slur.
Yeah. After World War II, the uh Yeah, they had a parliamentary
Yeah. They did not have they did not have emper uh imperial rule.
Imperial Japan ceased to exist. you consistently say you have
said actually I want I want to read from your newsletter because
if you ask what an isolationist is your newsletter a couple of
days ago you wrote
um so part of the reason they didn't the emperor is because Imperial
Japan had a lot of support for the emperor still and they thought
they could I believe they thought that they could actually um
like retain the support of the people if they let the emperor
stay in and there was some reason to believe although not for
sure there was some reason to believe that the emperor emperor
who I believe was young was being influenced by his generals
and that his generals ran most of the war and he was not really
the emperor who um who like he was not running the country right
um hold up
Ted Cruz just bring out a packet a printed out Alex Jones papers
yeah
I have I have the documents I Jerry I have the documents that's
what he's doing okay I want I want to read from your newsletter
because if You ask what an isolationist is. Your newsletter a
couple of days ago, you wrote, "Look at emails." Um,
"Iran cannot have a nuclear bomb and we're hoping to get back
to the negotiating table. We will see. There are several people
in leadership in Iran that will not be coming back," Trump said,
following the strikes. It's worth taking a step back and wondering
how any of this helps the United States. We can't think of a
single way.
Okay, that to me is the essence of isolationism. And let me just
ask you, when when the Ayatollah chants death to America, I believe
him. Do do you not believe him? Do do you think he doesn't mean
it when he says death to America? I think he hates America for
sure and I'm opposed to that. And do you think he's willing to
act on it? It's not just hate America, he also is leading a country
in for sure. So the question is
I can he just give the counter hypothetical of like Russia? Can
he give the counter hypothetical of China? There's a lot of countries
who hate America. You can't just you can't just drone strike
every country's leader who hates America. Okay, like Ted Cruz
has made all of his arguments here around the idea of a nuclear
Iran, right? A nuclear Iran doesn't exist.
That is not a threat to America, right? That that's not what
it is. And then he he he just does a whole bunch of disjoint
arguments that when you put them together don't make any sense,
right? That like Okay, can I ask something? Go ahead. What is
what is the actual reason Israel wants to
up Iran if they don't actually have nuclear weapons? Um because
Iran does represent a risk to them because Iran is one of the
powers in the region and Iran a stable Iran in the region like
Iran has been feeding proxies who fire weapons and missiles at
Israel. Uh obviously one of the biggest you know one of the biggest
rocket senders into Israel is Hezbollah. Hezbollah is entirely
funded by Iran. Iran funds terrorism against Israel. Right. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah, they hate they hate Iran and a stable Iran is one
that can continue to feed these pro weapons so they continue
to attack Israel and they hate Iran because Iran hates them.
They hate Iran because Iran funds terrorism against them. Iran
hates them because
I assume for a lot of the reasons that Arabs in the region would
hate Israel that is they see Israel as like a disrupting force.
Iran is not a what would you call it? Iran is not like an Arab
country, but I would imagine that they see Israel as like a major
disruption major major disruptionary force in the area. I guess
also they're an Islamic cal they're a Islamic theocracy. I'm
sure they have a lot of Islamic solidarity with some of the people
around there against Israel.
It's not an ethnic solidarity in the same way as a lot of the
Arab countries are though. Yeah. Is do you act in a way that
makes that more or less likely?
And that's a that's a tough call. It's something that you can
debate. One of the ways you shut down debate is by calling people
names like isolationist pretending they're like pro-Nazi or something
or as you did claiming I'm an anti-semite. That's not a way to
get
How come Israel can surgically all the top Iran military officials
but have to carpet bomb Gaza? Because Iran has some semblance
of a military and discipline and uniform and uniforms and order
and their people go places at certain times to make meetings.
They can be predictably found in certain areas. Uh they do not
all live underground. They do not hide like all of the time,
right? That's why Israel can surgically all of them because they
live in normal they're not like totally under the ground. Okay?
Like all of the people in Gaza are that's why they have the that's
why the bombing in Gaza has been so significant, right? All of
those people blend with the civilian population. Um like Iran
has a military. That's why Israel has been striking. That's why
there's been so little civilian death in Iran, right? because
a lot of their stuff for for better or worse like they're anti-air
and it's out in the desert, right? All I have seen is the headline
by the Pentagon are there being no nuclear risk in the near future
in Iran. But what were the particulars there? If it was just
a write up saying no definitive proof of nuclear weapons, but
nothing explicitly contradicts that notion and Israel had better
intel through MSAD, is it impossible that they are actually closer
to nukes than we think? Well, evil Johnny Bravo, unfortunately,
we just have three decades of Benjamin Netanyahu coming out and
telling people, well, they have nukes. They're like a week away
from a nuke. They're weeks away from a nuke. And that never being
the case.
So unfortunately, I am just going to opt against what MSAD and
Israel tells me because they have lied to me so many times. They
just lie to the world repeatedly over and over and over and over
and over and over again on this exact topic. Right? If they are
going to constantly lie about it every like every single time,
then yeah, I'm going to not take them seriously. when when international
agencies are saying there's no evidence of nuclear weapons when
the US through Tulsi Gabbard in March testifying no evidence
of a nuclear weapon from Iran. Okay. Yeah. I'm I'm just going
to go ahead and take everybody else's word for it. Israel's word
on whether or not there's a nuclear Iran Iranian threat coming
is about as good as the boy who cried wolf. Doesn't mean it's
impossible, but I certainly don't like I certainly don't take
him seriously. Okay. Can't take him seriously to a solution or
have a rational conversation that's way to make people be quiet
and I I'm against that. Okay. So if you don't like the label
isolationist, how would you look? Rand and I serve with Rand.
Rand is a friend of mine, but Rand opposes every military action
in every circumstance. You don't oppose every mil this whole
thing is infantile and you know that it is. It's a way it's a
way to call people reactions. Do you support them all and make
them be quiet? Give me another name. If you don't like that I'm
not trying to have you be quiet. We've been talking an hour and
a half. I'm asking if you don't like the name isolation is what
would you how would you describe it? I would I would describe
myself in the same way you falsely described yourself in this
conversation. What did I say falsely? You said that the only
thing that matters in a foreign policy decision is whether it
helps the United States. I didn't say the only, I said the predominant.
That's what I understood. So, let me revise what you said and
apply it to myself and say the only thing that matters is whether
or not it serves the United States. And I feel very stung by
what happened in Iraq, if I'm being honest, possibly because
I'm like you, I guess, I supported it and I saw us get drawn
into it in a way that nobody anticipated. And I saw the cost
just the $3 trillion.
And the cost on so many levels to the United States was just
so profound. I it was a mistake. Gosh, it reminds me of Kaiser
Wilhelm in 1914 saying, "My men will be back by the time the
leaves turn." And of course, that destroyed destroyed Christian
Europe. So, it's like you don't really know where these things
are going once the shooting start. That's Oh, I will say
referring to preWorld War I Europe is Christian Europe. As accurate
as it may be, I've never heard somebody refer to it that way
and not have some other views that go along. That's one of those
like giga red flags for me. The destroyed Christian Europe
that to me I'm just like holy. I
Yeah, like so many flags just went off like cuz people think
that World War I was started to destroy all the Christian monarchs
in Europe. I've heard this from Fuentes multiple times. I'm just
saying I hear that that phrase right there. It's not in and of
itself proof of anything. But when I hear that, I've never heard
that from somebody who didn't also have a whole lot of other
beliefs that go with it that I'm like, uhoh. Uh-oh.
It's my only point. And calling people names anti-semitis isolationist
to get them to stop talking is not the way to serve your country.
So I'm trying to have a real and serious conversation. And look,
I'm saying that most of the people who talk about that like the
the point of view they bring it up from or that I've seen like
Fuentes for example bring it up from is like oh it was like people
who made who made the first world war happened. They were the
propheteers of that and they knew that it was a way to destabilize
Christian Europe and get rid of the Christian monarchs and move
all of them into democracy basically to undermine Christianity.
That's like that's sort of the idea that they push at. Now, I
don't know if Tucker believes any of that, but I I I'll be honest.
I just never heard somebody describe his Christian Europe in
that way. That ex there's just something about it. Okay. I felt
the hairs on my arm go up a little bit. A lot of this has been
contentious. I I wish it had not because we started out by saying,
you and I agree vehemently on 80% of the issues. Uh this discussion
is focused on on the 20% where we don't. Um you know, I will
say look on Iraq, you look at the 2016 presidential campaign,
you had 17 Republicans running. If you set Rand aside,
uh and his views are are on one side. There were only two candidates
on that stage that opposed the Iraq war. Me and Donald Trump
were the only two. Everyone else thought the Iraq war was a great
thing. I think it was a disaster. So you and I agree on that
as well. In my view, you went I think your policy has gone too
far. So I mean, let me ask you, is there a military action Trump
has undertaken that you agree with? Because I've not heard anything
a military look, I would say it's really simple. I believe in
self-defense. It's why I keep firearms at home. I think it's
morally justified to defend yourself, your family, your property,
your nation. And so to the extent that you can deter a threat
through violence, violence always being the least appealing choice.
Violence always being if I can finish always being a tragedy,
I think you can justify the use of violence and self-defense.
That that's my personal view and that applies to me and to the
country that those are my views. That's not isolationist view.
It's not anti-Israel view. It's not anti-semitic view. Apologies.
Um it is I think a pretty common sense view. But my problem is
that lawmakers in Washington are light on the tail with these
things and they speak as you do entirely in moral terms. These
people are bad. These people are I'm not speaking entirely moral
terms. I'm not getting killing people who are trying to kill
us. If we had that's different, are you now? Because you told
me that the government of Iran is presently trying to Donald
Trump and that's undisputed. There's literally then why don't
you support military action right now against Iran? We are engaging
military action right now. Why don't you Why don't you support
offensive military action? We're bombing the crap out of Israelis
and we're supporting them. We We're bombing the crap out of them.
Well, Israel is I didn't they already get in a fight over this?
Didn't Ted already do this in this interview? There's a lot of
this going around. Okay. We are bombing Iran now. Wait, you mean
Israel? Yeah, Israel. Israel. Okay. So, why shouldn't the US
military defend its own president? I don't understand that. Look,
and it goes back to because you don't really believe it's true.
That's why everyone Hey, nobody disputes it. T on the moon. What
other conspiracies do you not believe? Was 911 inside job? I
mean, like what? So, where I've asked you the names of these
people. I've don't know the name of the Iranian hit. I know it
because the US military and the intelligence agencies have testified
before Congress repeated that Iran is trying to murder Donald
Trump and has hired hitmen. Do I know the name of the hitmen?
No. I'm sorry. And I don't think we do either because we would
apprehend them if we knew their names. Why don't you take it
seriously enough to support the Ayatollah in response to protect
our president? But you don't. I This doesn't make even make any
sense. And you're calling me an isolationist. If I believed that
was true, I would support military action against the government
of Iran. Okay, that's interesting because there is literally
our president. All right. Out of 535
members of Congress, I am not aware of one who disputes that
Iran is trying that Iran is trying to kill Donald Trump to murder
Donald J. Trump. That's not even the Looneyest Democrat doesn't
dispute that. So So I I don't You're saying if if you believed
what what is I think a I think Tucker should say is North Korea
trying to kill the president? Is Russia trying to kill the president?
Is China trying to kill the president? Is this just like something
that we don't know about? Are you telling us that every every
country is trying to kill the president at all that they are
trying to You think it's a fact? What is the fact exactly? Where
did in the United States? Americans. Yeah. He's not in Iran.
So they haven't hired Hitman. But are they the Hitman American?
I don't know. Oh, okay. I'm telling you what. And And by the
way, I'm I'm not the CIA. I'm not I'm not the Department of Defense.
I'm telling you what they have told us. I'm not disputing it.
I'm merely saying we are I'm not I'm saying the logic train has
a massive hole in it. If you believe that's true, then you should
by definition support the people trying to kill our president.
But you don't support that. So I'm wondering what's going on
here. Tucker, you took offense to the word isolationist. And
I I genuinely don't mean it as a pjorative. I disagree with it.
But if you don't like that term, I don't know how else to describe
what is a coherent foreign policy that says we're surrounded
by two giant nations. By the way, isolationism has long been
a a school of policy defense. I I'm not I'm not into the slurs,
the anti-semite stuff. I I just don't like that. I'm telling
you what I believe. So, but is there a single military action
front that you agree with? So, you really taking out general
money? Oh, I don't know. It turned out better than I thought.
I guess you said at the time it would Okay. Well, lead us to
World War II. I thought I was worried about it. I've seen that.
Hold on. What is that? Barry Q. 16 months. Let's go. Thank you
very Thank you. Thank you. Audio. Are you having audio issues,
Barry Q? Okay, never mind. Heads prove not the case. I've been
wrong as I have been for the 16 people taking out the ISIS caliphate.
But my Well, if we took the ISIS caliphate, why are they running
Syria right now? And you're for that. Why is that? What do you mean?
I didn't say I'm for that. You don't have to have a problem with
it. ISIS is now running Syria. You're like, we'll see. No, I
I mean, I know why. By the way, I know why. Assad topple. It's
hilarious. You know why is bad, but no ISIS runs Syria, but that's
that's fine. We'll just kind of wait and see on on ISIS. Not
a big deal. Not a big deal. Hold on a second. I want to get back.
You know why I don't care. and and why and you do your like trademark
smirky laugh. I know why you don't care what you're talking about.
What? Why don't I care? I don't know. Why? You tell me. Because
you think it's okay because they're not making angry noises or
something, but by your own standards, their ISIS is so immoral
that they must die. But now they're running Syria. And you don't
think that we should take military action against the government
of Syria because why? They're ISIS. What I said is I don't know
how good or bad it'll be. Look, I wasn't pushing Assad out. He
fell. He fell on his own in part because he was heavily supported
by Hezbollah and when Israel took out he didn't fall on his own.
The Hezbollah leadership he lost his base. But the current ISIS
leadership you don't think is bad. You can't say it's terrible
that ISIS runs a country. I I am concerned about it. Concerned?
Aren't you horrified? I want to see what they do. But you got
to wait and see attitude on ISIS. What? Why? Why? Oh, he he's
so he's been trapped so many times in this interview that he's
like petrified. He's like traumatized into thinking that he's
about to step into a trap. So he can't even say ISIS bad. He's
like, "We got to, you know, let's give them a shot. We'll see.
We'll see what happens on the government of Syria. They are not
actively that I am aware of trying to murder Americans." And
and that's a real dividing line. Are you trying to murder Americans
or not? I'm just saying it's a little weird that we wage a war
against ISIS and now they're running a country in the Mediterranean.
I think that people would be very very upset about that. That
you don't see. By the way, did you agree with Trump taking out
Albaghdaddy, the head of ISIS? I'm totally opposed to ISIS and
what I care about is results actually. And if taking out the
head of ISIS ends ISIS, I guess I'm for it. But now ISIS runs
serious. So I'm wondering where I mean my point is at the time.
I mean, I've taken so many different positions over the years,
some of which have been wrong. I really do my best to be honest
and correct if there admit that I was wrong. I'm not one of these
people like I've always been consistent. No, my views change
all the time because the facts change all the time. You're not
going to get consistency from me. You're only going to get sincerity.
Well, well, I look, I will say this and and look, I believe you're
sincere. I Yeah, but I'm not God. I'm just some guy watching
trying to figure out the right thing for me. And and I think
because
you believe you were mistaken and I agree previously, I think
you've overcorrected.
Overcorrected. I'm worried about turning this mess in Iran into
a much larger mess. That's the concern. And that's by the way,
that's a reasonable worry. Look, I know it's reasonable. And
I know you've been like you're like ready to call me all these
names for asking. You're just asking questions. Yes, I am. Does
ISIS really run Syria?
Well, it's a it's like a what is it? like ISIS K uh ISIS some
ISIS affiliated thing was one of the there were like 14 different
militias that helped overthrow
Assad
and I think ISIS or some of ISIS affiliated ones were one of
them were some of them there was um al-Qaeda al-Nusra
there was like a lot of different loosely affiliated militias
that took out Assad so it's some extremist Islamist group that
is running Syria now and I forget which one precisely so here's
my question to you if the Ayatollah is killed in Iran and he
very well could if there's a war. So I have just read in the
paper this morning that
Israel tried to take him out twice and Trump told them not to.
I have read that I don't have independent confirmation one way
or the other. You think that they should take him out? So, I
actually talked about it. As you know, I do a podcast every week,
Verdict with Ted Cruz, and I actually talked about it in the
latest podcast. And I said, "Look, I've seen the reporting that
says that Trump asked them not to take out the Ayatollah." And
what I said the podcast is, I think it's reasonable for them
to decide not to try to take him out. What they've done is targeted
just about the entire top level of the military, the people that
actually conduct the war. Um, oh my god. Do you remember?
No.
Um, I was just instantly I cringed at the thought that why does
this person have a podcast? Do you remember when Elon said that
the United States was going to have a podcast to talk to take
No. His whole Yeah. his Doge department was going to have a podcast
to explain
how the government was spending money and they were going to
I do not remember that, but I don't. That sounds horrifying.
Okay. It does sound horrifying. It sound horrifying. Yeah. Just
another one of Elon's uh business plan models that he never followed
through on. Yeah. Wait, are we Was Ted just talking about that?
I'm confused. Are you just putting out an awful idea from Elon?
No, because No, Ted just plugged his own podcast. He's like,
"Actually, I brought this up on my podcast blah blah blah with
Ted Cruz on the latest episode." Uhhuh. Me. Is he still a senator?
I believe so. Yeah. For Texas. The [__] is he doing
with the podcast? Um, almost certainly nothing good. Okay. Uh,
advocating for Israel. I don't know. I have no idea. Uh, it's
a very pro-Israel podcast. I I can see an argument that taking
out both the head of state and a religious leader could make
him a martyr and and could cause more problems than it's worth.
And by the way, if you take out the Ayatollah, I don't know.
I'm sorry, just one less. I'm pretty sure it's a way to funnel
money or to launder money for him. Yeah, maybe if he's getting
like a lot of donations. But I'm guessing that actually nobody
watches and nobody cares. Hold on. Bot views. Look it up. Uh,
never mind. Apparently, it's got
ratings and 4.6,000
uh or 4.6 out of five stars. Verdict with Ted Cruz, Premier Networks.
Apparently, he does a podcast all the time. Him and Ben Ferguson.
Where do I know this Ben Ferguson guy from? I know him from something.
What do I know him from? He used to be with Noles. Dan Crrenshaw
is one, too. I know this guy from somewhere. What do I know?
Ben Ferguson. Wait, that's No. No, I don't. I actually don't
know. He appears on Piers and stuff. Okay. Yeah. I don't I don't
know who the he is. Weird. Okay. Okay. All right. We continue.
The next guy isn't just as bad. And And so I am What happens
to the country? I I don't know. But you mentioned before and
I want to go back to this. She said something like uh you like
most other politicians are are engaged in in moral terms
and let me be clear I am talking about national interest. I am
talking about protecting America. So there are bad guys on planet
earth that I don't think we no rein Ruben I got no discount codes
or something. I don't think I have discount codes. I don't even
know how I'd make them. I would make one for you but I have no
idea how to do it. Should take out even though they're there
is a discount if you pay for a year. I think you get like 22%
off or something. Just so you know. Up to you. You do whatever
you got to do. Ruben Ruben, they're bad guys. I'll call them
bad guys, but but I'm not willing to use US military force to
take them out. In this instance,
what Israel is doing is taking out their capacity to build nuclear
weapons.
Why? Because they judge the the risk is too high if they nuclear
weapons. Understand that. I I mean, I understand that. I think
it's in progress. I think it'll probably be achieved probably
with US military support. Who knows? But the president said he's
for that. We've got 3D models coming out, guys. Soon to be soon.
Merch is coming soon. Okay, merch is coming soon. It'll be here.
And by the way, where the military support is most needed is
Fort, which is the under it's a bunker that's built under a mountain,
right? And Israel's taken out most of the rest, like Natans,
which is their big enrichment site. They bomb the hell out of
it. Fort was deliberately built deep into a mountain so that
Israel couldn't take it out. and and there's an active discussion
because the US has bunker buster bombs that are big enough to
take out Ford £30,000
and Israel doesn't. So So the one military piece nor the aircraft
to fly them they need to but hold on I can do discount codes.
I'll look at a discount code right now. Patreon discount discount
code what uh how do I get how do I make my Patreon discounts
better? How do I make Patreon discount codes? Here's I guess
what bothers me is that I said two weeks ago the real goal here
is regime change in Iran. It's not I think that's Trump's goal
and it's your goal. It's Israel's goal. I'm not attacking anyone.
I'm just saying it's important to be honest and not lie and not
attack people for telling the truth. So So I believe I've been
assiduously honest in this. But but words matter. You said the
real goal here is regime change. The [__] does assiduously
mean? Assiduously honest. Assiduous. Um did he try to pick a
word that says win it?
showing great care and perseverance.
Assiduous. Assiduous change. And it's your goal. And I want to
be clear. Well, you said it was your goal. I I want to be clear
because words matter. Do I support regime change? And would I
like a government that doesn't hate America and isn't trying
to kill us in Iran? Yes, that's a good outcome.
Is that the objective of these military strikes? I don't think
necessarily. I I don't know if it's Israel's. It's not my objective.
Should the US if Israel decides we're going to decapitate the
government and try to ferment an uprising against it, should
the United States participate in that operation in any way? Look,
I Okay, guys. Reuben Rubin just for you. Okay, here it is. Patreon
discount code 50% off the first month. patreon.com/jstlk.
Revenubin has gotten you guys a deal. Okay, you get 50% off.
Discount code is 660
E6. 50% off the first month if you guys sign up for the Patreon.
Okay, 50% off the first month. We're going to be doing uh we
got plans. Okay, we got plans for for Oiler content and stuff.
All right, there it is. patreon.com/jok.
That's it. It's right there. Why such a dumb code? Cuz they autogenerated
the code for me. But that is the code. You guys can get 50% off
if you sign up right now. You know what I could have I could
have done actually is I could just make it so it doesn't even
have a code. Can I can I just make it so it applies to everything
without a
No e dating for Oilers. Some Barry Q asked if you can allow E
dating for Oilers. No E dating for Oilers. But if you do join
the Oiler tier, there will be calls in which I will help you
uh wean away from the need for uh attention from the opposite
sex and seeking out the validation from Jesus Christ. our Lord
and Savior. Yeah. Also, if you do want to edate, it's JWDP tier
as everybody has said. Okay. Um, yeah, Ry, there's a there's
a browser source issue in Windows 11 and somebody fixed it and
they finally rolled it into one of their latest builds and now
it's fixed and so I I went and compiled the release candidate
build for the latest one and it works. So, it's all fixed. Let's
go. Except now I got rid of the TTS stuff and now we're back
to patreon.com/ja
50% off the first month. Oh my god, that's 50% off. Hold on,
I should put that in the Discord as well. Here, Ned Cruz literally
has book perfect example of a liar's nose
and treacherous mouth and his eyes look pushed up by his under
eyes, which shows dishonesty and immorality. Huh?
Other calls begin in month two? No, other calls are like right
away. Like this week for sure. It's just I don't know if it's
going to be tonight or tomorrow night. We'll see. I have not
called for Oh, if you sign up for the free tier of the Patreon
as well, guys. patreon.com/jc. Okay. If you sign up for the free
tier, you can receive gifts on the Patreon technically. Okay.
I don't know when that would happen. We'll have to see. But yes,
or the Ayatollah and and there is nations in war generally refrain
from attacking and heads of state. Now, the Ayatollah doesn't.
He's trying to kill Trump. We talked about that, but we shouldn't
punish him for it. Look, there has been a longstanding
nations in war have refrained from from heads of state. I have
not publicly called for the Ayatollah. What I've called for is
doing whatever is necessary to stop him from getting nuclear
weapons. In the first Trump term, what that meant was maximum
pressure. So, in the first Trump term, I spent a lot of time
urging the president to withdraw from the disastrous Iranian
nuclear deal that Obama had. President Trump agreed with me.
He did that and then I urged him to end the oil waiverss and
to sanction the hell out of the country and it ended up crippling
their economy. So, so Iran at the time was selling 2 million
barrels of oil a day. 1 million barrels, I'm sorry, 1 million
barrels of oil a day. When President Trump ended the oil waiverss,
it cut their sales to 300,000 barrels a day. They're on there
sales. Okay. From what I understand, doesn't Iran run a bunch
of illegal oil all over the place for different countries? Like,
they are sanctioned, but I do believe they still sell their oil
at fairly reasonable prices. Is there I want to say, and I'm
not 100% sure, but I want to say there's something between Russia
and and Iran where they help each other like illegally sell their
oil to people. At the end of the Trump term, the Iranian economy
was in shambles. They had massive inflation. I think the regime
was teetering. I think it might have fallen. I would okay give
me the year where the Iranian realale has not experienced mass
inflation. Okay, that economy is managed horribly. Use economic
sanctions and I would use moral persuasion to try to effectuate
if you Okay, so you topple the regime by whatever means what
happens then? How many people live in Iran, by the way? I I don't
know the population at all. No, I don't know the population.
You don't know the population of the country you seek to topple?
How many people live in Iran? 92 million. Okay. Yeah. How could
you not know that? I I don't sit around memorizing population
tables. Well, it's kind of rough. Okay, that one maybe not as
bad. Like he could have said roughly, you know, nine figures
or something. Maybe maybe he gets fine. But there's other Tucker
starts asking him more questions. Relevant because you're calling
for the overthrow of the government. Why is it relevant whether
it's 90 million or 80 million or 100 million? Why is that? Because
if you don't know anything about the country, I didn't say I
don't know anything about the country. Okay. What's the ethnic
mix of Iran? They are Persians and predominantly Shia. Okay.
No, it's not even you don't know anything about Iran.
he did say they're Persian. The Tucker Carlson bird on Iran.
You're a senator who's calling the government
about the country. No, you don't know anything about the country.
You're the one Tucker is kind of a little though. Okay. That
way of laughing and he kind of he's kind of who claims they're
not trying to murder Donald Trump. I'm not saying that who can't
figure out if it's General Solommani and you said it was believe
they're trying to murder Trump. Yes, I do. Because you're not
calling for military strikes against them in retaliation. And
if you really believe they're carrying out military strikes today,
you said Israel was right with our help. I said we Israel is
leading them, but we're supporting them. Well, this you're breaking
news here. That's where that's where the uh clip ends. That's
not even the first time he does that in this interview. That's
the second time he does it just in this interview where he's
like, "We're carrying out these strikes. You mean Israel?" Yes,
but like w with our help. But you said we weren't really helping.
Well, because the US government last night denied the National
Security Council spokesman, Alex Feifer, denied on behalf of
Trump that we were acting on Israel's behalf in any offensive
capacity. We're not bombing them. Israel's bombing them. You
just said we were.
We are supporting Israel. You're a senator. If you're saying
the United States government is that we're with Iran right now,
people are listening. Okay. We are not bombing them. That is
a big deal. That is a very big deal. Israel is bombing politician.
Why do you do to the snide? Oh, okay. What do you mean? Because
it's this is super high stakes stuff. It's this is a huge country
that borders a lot of other important countries. A lot of world's
energy comes from there.
You don't want another disaster. You don't want the Ayatollah
refers to Israel as the little Satan and America as the great
Satan. Do you believe him when he says it's the great Satan?
Do you think I do? Do you think if the Ayatollah could murder
both of us right now that he would? I do. I believe it. Tucker's
like, I'm in pretty good with Putin, so you know, he might hold
off. Putin might be a little upset if he iced me. Ted, you'd
probably be in trouble. Okay. I I assume no good faith on the
part of the Ayatollah. And if your implication is like I'm pro
Ayatollah or something. No, no, no. It's not good faith. It's
that just saying you're a lawmaker, you're a powerful person
in Washington, this is the most powerful country in the world.
If you're calling for toppling in government, it's incumbent
on you to know something about the country and to think through
the consequences of that. And you haven't and you don't. And
I'm saying that's ridiculous. Which, by the way, was the thing
that Ted Cruz said he had done when he started this whole thing.
Remember why he why he opposed the Syrian bombing? Why he opposed
overthrowing Assad when he thought they had a chance? Why he
opposed Obama trying to bomb Syria, right? It was all of the
things, hey, I don't know who will take it over. That power vacuum
seems really dangerous to me. Iraq's right there. Iraq's like
in turmoil right now. That seems like it'd be a really bad idea.
all of the things he talked about thinking about when he denied
when he said Obama doesn't have the authority to strike Syria.
This is crazy. He needs congressional approval, right? And now
when it's Trump going to strike Iran on behalf of Israel, he's
like, "No, it's just a bombing run, guys. We can totally do that.
You don't need congressional approval." It's like, "Oh, so you've
thought through all the things from Syria, all the stuff about,
hey, if this does result in regime change, who else is going
in? What's that going to mean for the region? What's that going
to mean for American interests?" He hasn't thought about any
of it. He doesn't care. I thought, okay, you you are you engage
in reckless rhetoric with no facts. And to be clear, I'm not
calling for the overthrow of
you put out a newsletter attacking Donald Trump and calling him
complicit Donald Trump. Yes, you
Will you keep how could you possibly take Donald Trump being
complicit in Israel striking Iran as an insult if you're arguing
that you are when when Tucker says why aren't you calling for
for military action against Iran? He says we are we are striking
Iran right now. Like what? How are you mad that he called Donald
Trump complicit in the strikes on Iran? You think he's complicit,
Ted? You can't get you can't fix that association in your brain.
has and and and by the way campaigned for Donald Trump it's like
after anti-semitism this is the last refuge you're an anti-semit
and you hate Trump I love Trump I I will read you put out a whole
newsletter saying Trump has abandoned America first and here's
what Trump said in response well considering that I'm the one
I know I just got owned in this debate but I'm going to tell
you what my dad said about you this is what my dad had to say
about you Mr. Carlson
jerk one that developed America first. And considering that the
term wasn't used until I came along, I'm think I'm the one who
decides that for those people who say they want peace. America
first has literally been a slogan for tons of politicians way
before Donald Trump. You can't have I think it was a Reagan slogan
at one point. I think there are hats that say America first,
Ronald Reagan like 84 or 88 or whatever the year he ran 80 1980
peace if Iran has a nuclear weapon. So for all of those wonderful
people who don't want to do anything about Iran having a nuclear
weapon, that's not peace. That was directed at you, man. This
is You got me busted. No, I'm just saying I'm my views. Look,
I I like Trump. I campaigned for Trump. I know Trump. I talked
to him last night. Not against Trump and you know that. I think
but you're against his foreign policy. I think that we should
be very careful about entering into more foreign worth that don't
help us when our country is dying. When you say don't help us
dying, look, yes, focus on our country. I'm all for it. But but
the the the naivity, you don't even know how much money this
costs. You don't know anything about the country whose government
you want to throw overthrow. And you're calling me reckless.
I want to stop a lunatic who wants to murder us from getting
nuclear weapons that could kill millions of Americans. You say,
"I can't see how that benefits America in any way." That is bizarre.
And by the way, isolationism, your foreign policy is the foreign
policy of Jimmy Carter and Barack Obama, and it doesn't work.
Yeah, I'm a big leftist.
This is so silly. I'm now I'm Jimmy Carter and Barack Obama.
Okay, by the way, when Barack Obama, again, I'll say it again.
When Barack Obama wanted to bomb Syria, Ted Cruz was against
that and said the president did not have the authority for uh
for military action. Okay? He needed congressional approval.
It was illegal for him to do so. So he when Obama was doing trying
to do the same thing, okay, Obama's trying to do very similar
things to what Trump's doing now. Ted Cruz was totally against
it. And now his insult towards Tucker Carlson is you're like
Barack Obama. Let me This is somebody said it. This isn't even
a double speak anymore. This is like triple speed. Like he's
gotten back on his own principles twice in the same conversation.
Just say one last thing. So how is your foreign policy different
from Jimmy Carter's? Seriously, please. But I I ask that question
seriously.
I don't even know what you're talking about. I I Jimmy Carter.
So, what century is this? I am the product of the last 25 years
watching carefully, being involved in the periphery, and I see
an unending string of foreign policy disasters that have impoverished
and hurt our unending string. An unending string. They would
include Afghanistan, Iraq, Libya, Syria, and our inability to
stop the Houthies, by the way, in Yemen, which exposes us as
weak, and I grieve over that. So these are No, he's wrong on
that. The Houthies just Dude, the Houthies is like bombing a
farm in Nebraska. Okay. Failures. You helped preside over some
of them as a member of the Senate. What What failures, foreign
policy failures have I presided over? Uh well, we were unable
to beat Russia in the war that you supported against Russia.
You you've been spending the last 3 years telling us that Vladimir
Putin is evil and we're going to beat him with other people's
children. And a million of those kids are now dead. You've never
apologized for that. That was by by the way look the level of
number of falsehoods you you lay out just in one statement are
are are rather you haven't supported the war against Russia.
Uh are are rather stunning. So the war against Russia was caused
which I have explained in great detail by by what? Oh, what is
he going to say?
I can't tell if he's going to say I literally have no idea. Is
he going to say something stupid? Is he going to say something
intelligent? I have no clue. By Joe Biden's weakness, but you
supported the war. No, if you want to talk, we can talk Russian
Ukraine. I'm happy to talk about it. I Do you think that's been
a success? No, it's been an absolute disaster. Okay. But you
supported it. Shouldn't you apologize? No, you should apologize.
I'm not I'm not going to engage in in the demanding of apologizing.
So, I'm going to I'm like, that's
doesn't matter if it makes any sense, guys. It's just Joe's fault.
Listen, Joe's Joe, stop beating on this old man. He literally
doesn't have a brain left to defend himself with. Stop it. Stop
it. Stop blaming all your problems on Joe. My point is all these
failures and no one ever says I'm sorry or do you just throw
out like you if you want to talk we can talk. Okay. I I I do.
I want to know why that seems like a true disaster for the United
States. You have supported it. And do you believe Joe Biden's
weakness caused the war in Ukraine? I think Joe Biden's aggression
caused it. His aggression? What aggression? He demanded that
Ukraine join NATO. How does that help the United Wait, DeAtt
Oh, we have versus fight. Okay, where was the demand? What didn't
he say? Like, oh, maybe they could join NATO. I thought that
was the thing was he was like, oh, maybe they could join NATO
or something. I thought he basically like accidentally said something
about NATO. Isn't that how that went? Uh, it would be a if we
got avatars with like football helmets on or something was like
protective helmets. That would be funny. Uh, football helmets
and water wings. Okay. at the same time. What's a water wing?
Do you not know what water wings are, Cherry? How does Cherry
not know what water wings are? Water wings?
They're like uh you got images. Water wings are these things.
They're little floaties you put on your arm so you can't drown.
Oh. Oh, floaties. Yeah, they're they're called floaties.
No, they're called water wings.
What is What do you Wings make you fly? This You're not flying
with these. Okay. Does the chat know that they're called What'
you call arm wings? Water Wings. Lots of people knew what I meant
when I said water wings. They knew. Lots of people knew. Yeah,
lots of people knew. Water wings. Water wings. Dude, is are they
actually doing it? The US is actually going to do it. Have we
struck her yet? Well, no. Apparently
apparently
the US has decided they will participate. I don't know. I haven't
seen like an official White House source saying so, but Bloomberg
seems to have said yes. The America has now decided they're going
to do it. They're going to participate. Oh, here's
hold on. Can I see it here? Cuz I I just I went to bloomberg.com
and I see this. Subscribe now for uninterrupted access. UN says
it has lost track of Iran's near bomb grade uranium. Okay.
Near bomb grade. Okay, dude.
So, I've seen Bloomberg. There was Bloomberg reporting earlier
that uh that Trump had said, "Okay, yes, we're going to do it.
We're striking Iran." Can I Can I find it anywhere else? It was
a tweet and I wasn't I didn't get a secondary source on it. So
I don't see anything on political uh on Politico
So I I'm not seeing anything concrete yet. We'll terrible idea
and I have vigorously opposed Ukraine joining NATO. Okay. So
that's what caused the war. No, it's not. All right. Did you
want to know what caused the war? Look, you do
only two of you knew what the he meant by water wings. And that's
because you guys are also Canadian. Eight of you are just you
just like chaos. That's it. Water wings.
Water wings.
Get it to 50/50. I need a surge in support for water wings. I
don't care if you actually know what water wings are. Start voting
for water wings right now. Vote for water wings. Do it. No, you
can't. This isn't an election. You can't ask people for votes.
I'm cheating. I'm trying to cheat influence. Vote for water wings
anyway despite not knowing what they are. vote. Water wings.
Water wings. Let's go. This is a rigged poll. It's rigged.
Uhhuh.
Uh, not rigged very well. It's like having a hard time catching
up. Any Anyway,
yeah, whatever. In any case, football helmets and floaties or
water wings, whatever you prefer. Okay, those are the avatars
we need to participate in this conversation. Okay, so it's Joe
Biden's fault about Ukraine and it's a it's basically an argument
between was Joe Biden so weak that he it up or was Joe Biden
so insanely aggressive, so maniacally demented and aggressive
that he made Ukraine he's like you have to you have to join NATO
now. Which one is it? Okay, so that's what caused the war. No,
it's not. All right. Do you want to know what caused the war?
Look, you do the dismissive. You're not actually interested in
facts. You're like, okay. Okay, tell me. It seems super OB. You're
absolutely right, and I'm sorry. That is a tick of mine. That
is wrong. And I mean this with sincerity. I'm sorry to do that
to you. I just think it seems so obvious that sending Kla Harris
to the NATO security to say you're going to join NATO is what
triggered the invasion days later. Seems so obvious that sending
Kla Harris to the NATO security conference to say you're going
to join NATO is what triggered the invasion days later. Okay.
So, can I This will take a few minutes to lay out because it's
complicated, but I think the facts matter.
I think two things caused the war in Ukraine. Number one, I think
Biden's incredible weakness and the disastrous withdrawal from
Afghanistan. Now, I believe we need to leave Afghanistan, but
not with the incompetence that involved that led to 13 servicemen
and women being murdered by terrorists there. The way Biden did
that was disastrous. And I think our enemies looked to the commander-in-chief
and said, "This this president is weak." And when when that that
withdrawal was so disastrous, I said publicly at the time, the
chances of Putin invading Ukraine have just risen 10fold. Right?
But secondly, and and and this is critically important. I agree.
That was
Oh, hold on. People are complaining about spamming. I I'll just
I'll just turn general chat back to uh Patreon participants only.
I will indeed. I'll do it every day. You want to give me a reason?
You want to give me a reason to do it? I'll do it. I'll do it
right away.
Boom. Boom.
Boom.
Patreon
ability to chat in general chat attached to the Patreon.
See you guys shortly. And it was a major
What's that? Oh, they can just chat and kick. That's true. Yeah.
Of our enemies all said, "Hey, this president is weak." And so
it invited and by the way look I despise war and and I think
weakness and isolationism
produces war because it it invites aggression from our bad guys.
It's why I agree with Ronald Reagan's peace through strength.
The best way you avoid war is being strong enough that your enemies
don't want to mess with you. But let's get back to Ukraine and
Russia.
Putin didn't wake up two years ago and decided he wanted to invade
Ukraine. He's wanted to invade Ukraine for
Putin has referred to the collapse of the Soviet Union as quote
the greatest geopolitical disaster of the 20th century. And Putin
has long been explicit his desire is to reassemble the old Soviet
Union and in fact reassemble
uh the the the Russian Empire that was okay. Is is Tucker's response
to this going to be? No, no, no. You see, 1,200 years ago,
we had the Kievan Roose, okay, over in Kiev, is he going to give
the history lesson that Putin gave him? Even bigger than that.
If you want to reassemble the Soviet Union, the natural place
to start is is Ukraine. Do do you really believe that Putin has
territorial designs on Eastern Europe? Yes. What countries? Uh,
he has said, but you can go and read his hold on. I I don't want
to lose the the Uhoh. We've gone. We've gone. Ted finally found
the way to win this conversation. Okay. Tucker also has absolutely
questionable interests that seem to be related to money because
I see no other motivation. All right. Based on a foreign country,
you know, paying him. All right. That's what that's where Ted
should have taken this immediately. And he didn't think about
it. Okay. He's accusing you of being paid off by Israel, Ted.
Call him a Russian shill. Call him a Russian shill. start talking
about Putin being a terrible person. You got it online. What
happened? We can go back and do that, but I I don't want to lose
telling the story first. So, let me let me explain this and then
if you want to go back, we can take all sorts of digressions,
but just give me a couple of minutes to to lay out the facts
of what happened.
He has wanted to invade Ukraine a long time and he's done it
before. In 2014, he invaded Ukraine, invaded Crimea. When Barack
Obama was president, he invaded the southern portion. He did
not invade the rest of the country. Why? And the reason is the
principal source of revenue for Russia is oil and gas and the
natural gas pipelines run right through the country of Ukraine
and he didn't want to jeopardize his ability to get gas to Europe.
Right. So in 2015
Putin started a project called Nordstream 2. Did anything happen
in
in terms of what wasn't there? A coup in Ukraine won by the Obama
administration.
Tucker unshockingly is ready to go to the mat for Russia with
his Russian propaganda. Let's go, Tucker.
Let me finish telling I I told you we'll take lots of digressions
in a second. Let me finish telling the the the the
2015, Putin began building Nordstream 2. Nordstream 2 is an undersea
pipeline that runs from Russia to Germany. The entire purpose
of Nordstream 2 is when it was completed and turned on, it would
let Wait, why did he start Why did he start Nordstream 2 after
he lost control of Ukraine after he is like the government he
influenced was thrown out of Ukraine? Why'd he start Nordstream
2 after? If the reason he invaded Ukraine was because he needed
to protect Nordstream, too. Ted, Ted, Ted, what are you doing,
Ted? How are you arguing like this, Ted? That doesn't make any
[__] sense. Russia circumvent Ukraine and get its
gas straight to Europe.
in 2019. Oh, wait, wait, wait. So, Oh, never mind. Never mind.
Oh, I should have Russia circumvent Ukraine and get its gas straight
to Europe. Okay. Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Nordstream 2 did not go
through Ukraine. I see. Never mind. In 2019, Nordstream 2 was
almost complete. And the conventional wisdom in Washington was
this is terrible, but there's nothing we can do about it. I didn't
believe that. So, I drafted sanctions legislation that was targeted
to stop the pipeline.
My legislation passed the Senate with overwhelming bipartisan
support. It passed the House and Donald Trump signed it in law.
Why would Can I ask why wouldn't you want Germany to have cheap
energy?
Be because it empowers Russia and I believe in making our enemies
weaker and our friends stronger. Has blowing up Nordstream made
Germany stronger? Um, not being dependent on Russia has made
Germany stronger. So, you think Germany is stronger now than
it was four years ago? I think not being dependent on Russia.
Germany has all sorts of problems and many of
how is Tucker winning by just putting on his face and going,
"Oh, you really think that? Oh, you really think that's true?
Oh, you really think that?" Ted just keeps saying things that
he are just rhetoric. He doesn't actually understand anything
about them. And Tucker is winning just by going, "Oh, you really
think that?" And Ted has no response. He's just It's It's so
domestic to their own politics. Hold on. Let me let me finish.
I'm I'm trying to No, but what you're saying it doesn't Germany
seems so much weaker now that its energy costs have spiked and
the manufacturing sector is collapsing because of that.
Let me
finish. I'm focused on America's interest.
I don't want Russia stronger because I believe Russia is our
enemy. You and I disagree on that. We can talk about that.
But I want our enemies weaker. I don't want to go to war with
Russia, but I want our enemies weaker. I don't want Europe dependent
on Russia. I don't want Putin rich with oil and gas revenues
and able to invest in his military and pose a threat to America.
So the sanctions legislation that I authored it passed. Putin
stopped building Nordstream 2 literally the day that President
Trump signed my sanctions legislation into law. He signed it
uh if I remember right at 700 p.m. on a Thursday. Putin stopped
construction at 6:45 p.m. So, the sanctions legislation worked
and it killed the pipeline. The pipeline laid dormant for over
a year, just a hunk of metal at the bottom of the ocean. Joe
Biden came into office. He was sworn in on January 20th, 2021.
Putin resumed deep sea construction of Nordstream 2 4 days later,
January 24th.
He did so because Biden had foreshadowed weakness on that this
issue. That foreshadowing was accurate because several months
later, Biden formally waved the sanctions on Nordstream 2 and
let Putin complete the pipeline.
Who asked him to do that? Why do you think Biden did that?
I'm I'm thinking that was like, okay, I don't know for sure,
but it seems to me like, wasn't that around the start of the
time Germany was like starting to have major energy crisises
that like they'd shut down their nuclear plants and they were
running into all kinds of issues? I feel like that could have
easily been Europe being like, "Hey, we uh we're feeling the
heat here." Okay, this it's we're having a hard time running
any AC. In January of 2022, I forced a vote on the Senate floor
to reimpose sanctions on Nordstream 2.
The week of the vote, President Silinsky in Ukraine publicly
called on the Senate, please pass this sanctions legislation.
It is the last best hope of stopping Russia from invading Ukraine.
At the same time, the government of Poland put out a formal statement
from the foreign ministry to the Senate calling on the Senate
to pass my sanctions legislation and said, "If you do not, Putin
will invade Ukraine."
The day of the vote, Joe Biden came to Capitol Hill. It's the
first time in his presidency he had done that. He went to the
Democrat senator's lunch and he personally lobbyed them on this
issue. Not any other issue. This was his number one issue that
he came to lobby them on.
They came out of that lunch. Every Democrat had voted with me
twice against Nordstream 2. 44 Democrats flipped their vote.
They voted in favor of Russia, in favor of Putin, and four weeks
later, Russia invaded Ukraine. That was the direct cause of the
war. And if Trump had been president, there would be no war.
So, may I ask, I of course disagree with your analysis um completely,
but I want to be respectful. And so, tell me what you disagree
with. I it's it's such a long conversation. I've spent the last
couple of years on this and I just respectfully disagree with
with your analysis, but I don't doubt your sincerity that you
believe that Putin is our enemy, that it's Western Europe should
not be allowed to use Russian energy. I mean, you seem to really
believe. Look at this timeline. We have Tucker Carlson pushing
back on Trump.
yeah,
T, Dude, I don't even know. The sad thing is is like I think
Tucker's asking some good questions, but like now I like watch
this whole thing and now watching him like absolutely slobber
all over Putin's balls at the end of this, it's like dude, is
he is this just what Putin wants or does he have like only is
is only on Russian issues he like sucks Putin's and then everything
else he's allowed to have his own opinion. I have no idea now.
Now I feel like uncomfortable for thinking he was doing well
earlier. I'm I know he was doing well. Like I was evaluating
the the statements on their own, but it's just up that I have
to listen and and I have to watch him like suck Putin's. It's
just bizarre these things. My question is about results because
I think it's relevant to what we're seeing now in Iran. You look
back after having you personally voted to send billions and billions
and billions of US tax dollars to Zilinski to support his civil
service and the war against Russia and all this stuff. Can you
say that what you did
So, I can say what I did personally, sanctioning Nordstream 2
worked and prevented a war. And if Trump had still been there,
if the sanction had been in effect, there would be no war. I'm
in favor of avoiding wars. But once the war broke out, you voted
to fund it to the tune of billions and billions and billions.
And to be clear, and did that work? Okay. To be to be clear,
what I voted for, I voted for the initial trunch of funding and
then I voted against the subsequent one. So, it hasn't worked.
So, I've been in between. I haven't been on the full Ukraine
fullthroated hawk side or the anti from day one. I voted for
the initial tranch of funding because I wanted Russia to lose.
I think the Biden administration administered it in a horrible
way. I think they wasted a ton of money and I think what they
did was actually incoherent because they were funding both sides
of the war. Okay. Um
I'm at a crossroads here. I don't know that I care to
I super don't care about like the Russian conversation they're
having, but I it's only like 10 minutes left. Yeah. Should we
finish it? I'm I'm gonna I'm going to play it and I'm going to
start looking for what we're going to next. I'm not 100% sure
what we're going to next. I've got other things in my docket.
I've got like lots of things to go to. Yeah. Yeah. Speed it up
a little bit. I was very vocal and and among other things, flooding
$100 million to Iran, which was used among other things to help
the nuclear program, but also to make drones that Russia used
to fight. I'm not going to defend the B administration. um really
did a lot to wreck the United States. Yeah. The most damaging
administration and where we sit now, Russia is stronger. It's
closely allied longterm with China. I don't know that Russia
is stronger. I don't think that's right. Okay. Um I think it's
pretty obvious that it is, but it's certainly not destroyed.
Um and it's allied longterm with China. Um maybe that look that
there's no doubt Biden's foreign policy drove Russia into the
arms. That's concerning. They also have a long history of Adam.
Western Europe is weaker and more in debt. The United States
is weaker and much more in debt. Hold on. So you I
agree. We're agreeing. Here's my question. Have you questioned
any of your previous assumptions? Did you play any role in this
at all? Are you responsible at all? Of course. And like you,
you said, "What have you learned?" Of like you, you said you've
changed your mind. I I voted for the first funding of the Ukraine
war and I voted against every subsequent funding stream because
it wasn't working. And I looked at what was happening and said,
"This is not working." And had the money been spent in an intelligent
way and not wasted. And had it been successful, I might have
been willing to fund more. It wasn't. I don't understand how
either of these people Okay, I understand completely how they're
doing it. But I don't understand how they seem to not No, I'm
not watching. No, no, I didn't watch that. Gigachs. No, we don't
watch children. We don't watch like kids content here. Is please,
if you want to watch children, go to a different channel. Anyway,
um I don't understand how both of these people, Tucker and Ted,
both of them are refusing to acknowledge that as far as like
funding goes, funding Ukraine, okay,
funding Ukraine is massively beneficial to the United States.
It sucks that Ukraine's getting invaded, but sending a couple
javelins to Ukraine to like all of Russians, all of Russian produced
weapons from the past like 10 years to destroy it all, basically
render their economy like deadlocked for a tiny for like basically
your military off sale. It's an amazing decision. It's some of
the most economically efficient decision-m the United States
has ever done. And both of these people are somehow arguing over
how that's bad. I don't get it. Successful. So, I voted no. And
and the war is going to end. Look, President Trump campaigned
on ending the war. I think he's frustrated because Putin has
been less than eager to reach a deal to end the war, but it's
going to end. You're not going to see another dollar. He wants
to end the war. Um,
I think Zalinski
has behaved horribly. I think his Oval Office meeting will go
down in history as the worst Oval Office meeting of any leader
that has ever come to the Oval Office. I think he behaved like
a pompous ass. And I think he is unrealistic. I think Zalinsky
spends his time with Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer in the New
York Times and he believed he was going to the Oval Office as
a resist figure and I think he's doing real damage to his country
right now. You described him many times as a hero. Uh I don't
believe I don't recall ever using the word hero. I will say look
I'm not I'm not a Zilinsky cheerleader and and I'm not in the
business of saying everyone we support has to be a sage and everyone
we oppose has to be a villain. I'm not in the morality game.
I'm in the US interest game. Why did I want Nordstream 2 stopped?
because it would strengthen Russia and Russia is our enemies.
It's entirely US interest. Did you support the industrial sabotage
against it? Blowing it up? Um, so I think you believe America
did that. Is that right? Of course. Okay. I think the chances
of that are zero. You think Russia did it? No, I I think Ukraine
did it. Okay. I thought it was basically like, didn't they find
like I thought there was like a ton of evidence that Ukraine
did it at this point.
Isn't it like clear that Ukraine blew up Nordstream, too? So,
I don't know. So, I don't know who did it. Um, in terms of the
theories that have been put out there, um, the idea that Russia
blew up their own pipeline never made any sense to get all that.
That just I can't even articulate why they would do that. The
idea that Biden did that, look, I could see it being in US interest
to do that to blow up Nordstream, too. I just think Biden was
too weak. I don't believe Joe Biden. But are you in I guess you
and so so that leads the Norwegians, the the Ukrainians, NATO,
whatever. Look, that leads me to you know who benefits and and
it leads me to think either the Ukrainians blew it up or Ukraine's
allies. I don't think Biden did because I just Biden was so weak.
I don't think he would give the order. I I find that implausible.
But you're in favor of it. I look I was in favor of stopping
it. I think I think blowing it up is is a was a good thing. So
I'm I'm supportive of that, but I don't think America did that.
I I don't think Biden gave that order. But in general, I don't
see Trump giving that order, but he wasn't in office. Yeah. And
you think that the largest act of industrial sabotage in history
helped our allies in Western Europe or other NATO fellow NATO
members? Look, I got to say, I don't understand. And for some
reason, you
are really invested in defending Russia. I don't get that. I'm
not
You don't get it. You don't get it. Ted doesn't want to do the
like the al the He doesn't want to do the thing he accused Tucker
of doing to him. Okay. Backing the other direction, but he gets
it. He knows exactly what he's saying. The shoe is just on the
other foot now. You I'm genuinely like I don't get why you're
you're so passionate about defending Roger.
Actually, I was defending Western Europe, the the home of my
ancestors, and that um you know, tripling their energy costs
and destroying their industrial base. No, no, no. Not no. The
home of my ancestors. See what I'm talking about with you see
these little pieces of language that come up from Tucker. Okay.
Kaiser Wilhelm destroying Western Europe with World War I. Yeah.
Christian destroying Christian Europe with World War I. And Western
Europe, the home of my ancestors. There's just a couple things
that he says. I feel like I could feel I can feel the hair standing
up. I I always know cuz like sometimes I I'm like a conservative
in some ways. I can like talk to people like this and then I've
had too many bad experiences now where like I'll talk to them
and then I realize they've got some other beliefs that I just
don't go with at all. Um I I
just can tell. Okay. You have a beer with Tucker and then you
you have a second beer and after the second beer he starts talking
about Yeah. He starts talking about the the Holy Roman Empire
or Prussia or retaking Constantinople.
Okay. And and then you're you're in some very dark areas after
that. Okay. It's not great. No, not like you just accused me
of being an anti-semite, an isolationist, and a Russia lackey.
I've not called you a neocon once, which you are, but I haven't
That's absurd. Yeah. Those neocons that oppose the Iraq war,
but like that that's But okay, but I haven't called you that
because name you just said which you are. So you just called
that called me that. You just did. I I guess what I'm saying
is you're triggered because I use name calling. I get it. I was
triggered when you called me names and I'm triggered once again
that you're calling me a Russia defender when in fact I'm defending
Western Europe. And I don't think that you do our enemy. I Well,
he's literally our enemy. You are funding a war against him.
But do you think he is our saying we're his enemy? Do you think
Putin is our enemy? I think it is a tragedy that your policies
your policies specifically yours helped drive Putin into the
arms of China forming a block that's larger than us. So you won't
answer that
It is. Dude, it's so funny. It's actually just the shoe exactly
on the other foot now. Right. where Tucker looks really bad.
Why do neither of these two, okay, if you're not funded by these
countries? Why do you look so bad answering questions about it?
Why wouldn't you just honestly just come up with some good? Even
if you are funded by them, okay, if you're funded by these countries,
just come up with better answers to the questions when people
ask you. Don't look so caught off guard and so tongue tied the
second you get asked. I don't He is literally our enemy right
now. That is a tragedy for the United States. No, no, you're
saying but you won't say he is our enemy. Look like in what sense?
I don't want to be enemies with Russia. It doesn't help us at
all. It may help some people in the United States, but in general
I don't want to be at war with Russia. I don't think it is in
our interest to be at war with China. That is But listen, no
doubt. And I want Russia and China attention. So I agree with
you there. But but I think Putin is a KGB thug. I think he is
a bad man. Now I don't want to go to war with him over that.
But but I'm not naive. And like uh Moody Morgan, if you're unaware,
I guess um right around the time that Tenant was this Tenant
media company was paying people to to uh post like Russian propaganda
or they're trying to get them to do pro-Russian talking points.
They're giving out a bunch of Russian money to random influencers.
They also paid those same influencers to repost and support the
Tucker Carlson grocery shopping video. Okay. While Tucker Carlson
was on a paid vacation to Russia and meeting with Vladimir Putin.
So although it's not a part of the same trunch of funding, it's
not like the same. So I don't know why I said trunch like Cruz
just did. It's not a part of the same funding or the same company
with tenant media, but the tenant media people, the Russian shills
who are actually telling them what to do were saying, "Oh, you
need to go post this Tucker Carlson interview right now. Go post
it and talk about how awesome it is to live in Russia right now."
So while we don't know that he's paid by Russia, certainly is
weird that the people who are literally being paid by Russia
were being told to post his grocery shopping tour.
Yeah. So almost certainly Tucker's paid by Russia.
You think now that Destin News is paid by Israel? I don't care.
I don't think about it. Like I watched your He's a bad man. He's
a bad man. Okay. Look, I watched your episode where you went
to the Russian uh grocery store and I'm I'm Was that disloyal,
do you think? It was just weird. It was like a promo video for
Russia and I don't understand. I'm
When Ted goes, I don't understand why you seem to be supporting
Russia. I don't understand why you seem to refuse to call Putin
a dictator. I don't understand why you seem to be hesitant to
call Russia an enemy. Oh, he did understand. He knows about the
grocery shopping video. He knows about all of it. Okay. Well,
I'm not attacking you when I ask why because I'm genuinely like
I don't like when And when I when I ask you why you were so horny
to post that video of you doing a Russian grocery shopping tour,
you said Russia was way cheaper than the US. I wonder how this
everything's so cheap here. It's such an amazing place. Oh my
god. And when I ask you about that, I'm not attacking you or
implying anything, Tucker. Okay. This is why he got called a
feline earlier. Okay. Cuz he's a feline. You call me something.
You weren't attacking me. You were just noticing. But but may
I ask be lion ted you a question. So here he's just noticing.
Well, let me just answer yours by saying the United States, the
bid administration with your help, full support um began this
war on Russia in response to their invasion of Ukraine. And one
of the things they was they kicked Russia out of Swift the international
financial system. And my first response was it's going to really
hurt the US dollar which it has and I hope someday we can have
a conversation about that. Um it's really really hurt the one
thing that we needed which was to retain dollar uh supremacy.
So, I was interested in the in the economic condition. By the
way, that's a reasonable point and a serious conversation. I'm
aware. I'm aware. And I was But I can agree with you. Like, no,
but I was accused of being I think it's weird that you went to
a Russian grocery store and said it was prosperous. No, my It
was weird. That was very weird. It looked like a commercial.
It looked like a commercial. Isn't this wonderful? Like it wasn't
It was a commercial against the efficacy of sanctions.
sanctions against Russia, which you casually and enthusiastically
imposed, scoring a little moral victory every time, had no material
effect that helped the United States.
They had a material effect of making it bad for Russia to break
the international order, which helps the United States long term.
How does Tucker not understand that a stable international order
is beneficial to everybody on the planet? Russia is back stopped
by China, and when you and I recommend that you go there and
see it, it is way nicer than Washington DC. Way nicer to me.
That's a
What?
Dude. God. Tucker had such a good start to this interview and
now it's just embarrassing.
Oh, that's just brutal. That's just brutal. Tragedy. I was horrified
and angry at my leaders, including you. It's like, I want to
live in a country that's nice. Like, low food costs and no homeless
people. I I don't understand why that's too much to ask. So,
do Okay. Uh,
we need to find a country that's up and coming. Okay. Nigeria
maybe. I think Nigeria is like the big economy in Africa, right?
I need to find a country that I can just start shilling for and
then I can have the Ted Cruz argument. I am resolving now to
be Nigeria's number one defender if I ever make it anywhere in
politics. Okay, resolving right now. We love Nigeria. Nigeria,
please. Our coffers are open. We need funding. Hello. Any any
rich Nigerian princes out
No. Is Russia like can you even be homeless in Russia? Isn't
it like so cold there all the time?
Uh outside of their far west part. Yeah, probably. Cue the eclipse.
Oh, we need to pick a different country.
Uh, no we don't. Just kidding. They don't even know. They don't
even care there. Okay. They're not American. They don't care.
But also,
I don't know. Also, I'm going to get worse with Iran. No, I just
want lower food costs. How's that? So look, it's a weird argument
that you do often, which is listen, things are crappy in America.
Liber, liberals have done bad things to America, so we shouldn't
worry about any liberals. Republican senators don't care about
us. They're focused on other countries. You wrote that Oh, yeah.
I think in like Yeah. In a lot of Russia, it is quite cold.
But it's also cold where I live. So it's very much the same thing.
Our country and homeless people live here, trust me. population,
but not more than DC. Not more than LA, probably.
Um, no, there's not a lot. They And in DC, they have like what?
Tunnels and stuff like that because of the subway system. Yeah.
It's just annoying to use that like that as a
Um, true, true. I guess so. Is dying and you don't care because
you're focused on Putin. So, so you believe that I don't care
about America. I guess you believe Donald Trump doesn't either.
Like, nobody cares. I believe that your focus is way too on other
countries. It's way too focused outward. The money that you send
abroad could be used here and should be. What money did that
I send abroad? By the way, I emphatically agree with you. I I
emphatically agree with with You don't even know. You don't even
know, Ted. Ted, you don't even know. Donald Trump's, for example,
dramatically slashing US ID. I I think the only reason we should
be deploying that is to benefit US interest, national security
interest, and keep Americans safe. And and so how much did you
vote to send to Ukraine? Look, you're in about $80 billion. 80
billion. Yeah. So So you you're in you love just giving these
broad characterizations that are not accurate. I I'm I'm genuinely
puzzled. Look, I don't want to go to war with Russia. I I I but
I don't think they're our our friend. I think Putin I agree.
I think Putin is a murderer. I think he's a liar. And I think
he does not wish well on America. Okay. And there's a difference
between saying that just like Reagan referred to the Soviet Union
as an evil empire and Putin was in the KGB. Look, my father was
imprisoned and tortured in Cuba. I hate communists. It was actually
Batista that tortured my dad. My aunt was imprisoned and tortured
by Castro. I hate communists. I think communism is evil. And
so I think there is a value to there is nobody who stands up
to communist China more in the Senate than I do because I think
they're evil. Do I want to go to war with China? Of course not.
That would be ridiculous. But I think we have all sorts of tools
to stand up to our enemies. And I think China is engaged in a
thousand-year war against the United States. They're trying to
do this. We're so well over the map. We were family in prison
in Cuba and China, all this stuff. I just I I agree with you.
I'm totally opposed to communism. Always have been. I don't think
that Putin loves us. I
Tucker is totally lost. Basically, Tucker got called out on that
grocery thing and he has not recovered. We're all over the map.
I'm distressed by the moral condition of most leaders around
the world. Most of them. They all kill people. I'm against that.
I'm just saying I wish the focus here. Can I say something? I
I actually don't agree with that statement. They all people there's
a moral relativism. So I don't think Donald Trump is a murderer.
He doesn't people we don't have Donald Trump a murder. You just
said world leaders all people and and there's a moral relativism.
I'm hardly a moral relative. But you are you just that statement
was the essence of an anti-semite and isolationist moral rel
saying I'm against people in general so and hyperventilating
about how Putin was in the KGB or whatever. I just want to serve
American interest.
Uh-huh. And pushing. It was because he was mad that he applied
Putin's China is not in our interest at all. And you helped do
it and you haven't apologized. And and by the way, you're the
cheerleader. I helped drive him into China is a complete lie.
You funded the war against him. No, I I authored the legislation
that shut down Nordstream 2 that prevented the war and and if
Trump had still been in the White House, we would have had the
war. And and look, the comment you made that the reason things
like moral relativism are so dangerous, oh, everyone people,
no, there is a difference. United States. We don't have concentration
camps. We don't torture and murder people. You look at China
where they've got a million prisoners in concentration camps.
You look at Putin where he's got prisoners in Siberia. He he
tortures and murders his political opponents. Donald Trump doesn't
do that. America doesn't do that. And by the way, other countries
don't do that. I see the game. It's like I'm
distressed. No, I'm responding with facts. You don't like the
facts. The I don't even know what facts you're talking about.
I'm not saying that Trump puts people in concentration camps.
I I campaigned for Trump. I love Trump. So do I. Okay. So this
has nothing to do with Trump. I'm merely saying when you said
every world leaders people it emphasis on what's happening inside
the country that's it is there a moral difference between America
and our enemies is there a moral difference between America and
what is it but articulated it's valuable to say why why are we
a better country founded on better values than China I'll tell
you why and I know I because the whole purpose of America is
to protect the god-given rights that each person possesses by
virtue of being created by God by being human. That's the point
of our founding documents and no other country articulates that
in the way that we do. Oh god. And that's that's what I love
about America. My family's been here a long time. I'm never leaving.
So I really love the country. Despite going to a Russian grocery
store, despite asking questions about APAC, I love America is
the truth.
Uh-huh. And I love Trump. So, but I just want more emphasis on
America. That's it. I emphatically agree with America first.
I think Donald Trump does as well. And I think his foreign policy
has been vigorously protecting that. And I I agree with the president.
Good. I
I emphatically agree with America first. Except Israel needs
to be somewhere in the mix. I emphatically agree with America
first. Except, you know, we probably shouldn't say bad things
about Russia. Okay, guys. Wow. We got two We got two real patriots
over here. Okay. They love America first. As long as you're getting
a country from a check for a country outside of America. In that
case, America First is awesome. Well, I appreciate you taking
all this time. Sure. And I know you didn't. Okay, that's that's
the end, guys. What a what an interview. Wow.
So good.
Israel is basically a satellite of America, though. Eh, maybe.
I did not like this. I just read this. It's not fun. If you're
raised in a community of people like Tucker and Ted, the way
I was, you would be enjoying what is happening here so much more
than you can imagine. Uh, I think it's pretty because those two
people have a lot of hold over, well, at least Tucker has a lot
of hold over a huge portion of the American population, right?
I feel like having absolute who seem to be beholden to other
states as major thought leaders in your country seems pretty
scary. But maybe you can enjoy that. I don't know. Seems rough.
According to we read a part of this earlier, but the fact that
it's
I'll get through it and then I'll explain why it's disconcerting.
Okay. According to Bloomberg, US President Donald Trump's rhetoric
against Iran has shifted significantly in recent days as political
allies have convinced them that Tyrron is close to obtaining
a nuclear weapon as suggested for months by Israel. Oh, well,
maybe some of those allies have a really good idea of what's
happening. Or maybe it's a idiot who's been telling people to
go to war with Iran for the past decade because he's totally
beholden to Israel. It's Lindsey Graham, Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham of South Carolina, as being the primary voice urging the
president to consider military action against nuclear facilities
in Iran, according to people familiar with the discussions. As
President Trump is said to have had multiple calls with uh recently
with Graham, it's Lindsey Graham.
Lindsey Graham's not even on a security
Where is Lindsey Graham getting this information from? Oh, wait.
Actually, I don't know that he's not on Oh, he might be on some
committee right now. What What committee? What committee is Lindsey
Graham on? Lindsey Graham
Where is Lindsey Graham?
Lindsy. Oh, budget committee. Judiciary appropriations. Okay.
No, he's not on an intelligence committee. Okay. This don't know.
He don't know. What are we doing?
Yeah, I at Metacafe. We reported on this already. I There's not
really much more to say. US officials prepare for possible strike
in Iran in coming days. Yeah, I know. I know. I know. I know.
I
I know.
Okay.
Okay. Are we ready for a little bit of a light-hearted switch
up here? I kind of wanted to watch this video a couple days ago
when it was posted. Never got a chance to watch it. Kidology
video. Tik Tok's obsessive boy mom. Okay, this is like a super
uh mom with a really inappropriate relationship with her kid.
Cherries.
I think it'd be very funny.
Oh, there are cherries on her shirt.
RIP Salvation. We'll get Salvation back. Okay. I didn't mean
I didn't think he was going to I was like bullying him. I I didn't
think he'd take it. I didn't think it was that bad. But we we
love that guy and he's gone and we miss him
Don't come back. It'll only get worse.
Moved up. Jesus Christ.
Uh, okay. Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu, we are on day six
of Operation Rising Lion. We began this campaign in order to
remove two existential threats to the state of Israel. The nuclear
threat and ballistic missile threat. We are advancing step by
step to remove these threats.
Oh god.
I sorry. I don't care. Speak English. Speak English. If you want
to propagandize me, speak English. He He would have an English
version of that. I guys need a little light-heartedness. Okay.
Also, here's the Steve Bannon one that I wanted to watch. Donald
God. Unfortunately, we've got this one loaded up at some point.
I might watch this later, like way later. Okay. But right now,
little bit of a light-hearted, fun romp through some Tik Tok
drama, some little Tik Tok story curated for us by Kidology.
Okay, the last one of these we watched was quite good. So, I'm
looking forward to this one as well. The one in the wife tubers,
very cool stuff. All right, I'm going to get some water cuz I've
already finished all my water and get a drink, use the bathroom,
and I'm going to hit play and I'll be right back. Okay, but I'm
excited. Let's check it out. first prom. I do not have to explain
myself to you guys. I'm so excited that this day is finally here.
Cannot wait for y'all to see my dress. I have been planning this
for a while.
It's going to be like the perfect mother son matching moment.
Sometimes whenever um I don't have any cash and you know that
you have some in your room in your wallet, I go in there and
I get it.
My dress is black and date dress is red. I'mma come snuggle with
you. Okay. Yeah, it's my baby boy. It really doesn't matter as
long as thinks I look beautiful. Don't he look cute carrying
my purse? What? Gentlemen, y'all get to get ready with this crazy
boy today. They're back. The toxic boy moms of Tik Tok are back.
Rebranded, repackaged, and repurposed. ready to let loose their
unbridled and passions for their darling little boys onto the
world. And in recent weeks, one particular boy mom has gone absolutely
viral. And diving into her content and story has been it's been
intriguing in seeing how this boy mom is simultaneously trolling
the internet and is somehow still a boy mom. It's weird. It's
frightening. It's introspective. And I need to know your thoughts
because the Lauren Cameron Glass situation is a
Now, I don't have a father, which is why I'm primed to one day
project all my emotional needs and trauma onto my son, but I
pray that you all have fathers and very healthy relationships
with them. Apparently, Father's Day is just around the corner.
And one thing I always see the dads at my gym wearing that I
never understood were headphones. So, this Father's Day, as a
bread winner to my cat and my partner's dog, I got myself a pair
of Raycon's Everyday headphones. Now, Raycon's everyday headphones
are the perfect gift for your dad or for you for every and any
activity. I personally love wearing my everyday headphones when
I'm at the gym, step mastering it up, or when I'm reading and
just need to zone out completely. And that's why I especially
appreciate Ray lies. What's up?
She's lying. Those headphones suck.
Okay. All right.
I wouldn't know. But wait, why do they suck? Evil Johnny Bravo.
Yes, this is Cherry. I have been here this whole time.
The do you mean is that Cherry?
I don't know if he meant in the ad or
Oh, no. No. Die.
Okay. He's just being racist. Okay. All right. Yeah. Cool.
All right. So, this is about a boy mom. Okay. This is going to
be disturbing
and intriguing at the same time. All
All right.
Con's active noise cancellation. It is so rare to have such effective
and high quality noise cancelling functionality in a pair of
headphones, especially at the under $100 price point, which is
precisely what you're getting with Raycon. I cannot hear anything
around me bar my new favorite EP which feels like it's enveloping
my entire environment. Personalizing my headphones to balance
sound makes them perfect for listening to classical music. And
when I'm listening to an audio book, I can easily switch over
to pure sound so I don't miss a single word. And then when I'm
at the gym working out and trying to get that adrenaline rush,
having my headphones on bass sound makes for the most bass boosted
gym experience ever. And this is all because of the headphones
360 personalized.
Nobody say it. Do not say it. Do not say it. I want talk over.
I see you. Don't say it. Immersive surround sound. And just like
I love to fully immerse myself in my musical experiences. Your
daddy's
sorry.
Trust me, daddy. Your fathers will love these headphones. Not
just for their premium features, 40hour battery life, a quick
charge function, awareness mode, the headphones ergonomic design
to make these babies wearable all day long, but also because
they are simply gorgeous. They look amazing on, are fully adjustable,
and are available in fun new colors to suit any taste. Raycon
start at half the price of other premium. I don't know why I
keep kept watching her advertisement when I actually came back.
I have no idea. Thanks so much to Raycon for sponsoring this
video. And a heartfelt thank you as well. That was a very long
ad.
for watching and supporting my content. So, I'm given these opportunities.
I really, really do appreciate it. Now, I just want to be clear
from the get-go. I like Lauren. She's spunky. She's funny. She's
human. I actually make sure that all the influences I cover I
like or find interesting because, well, you know, it makes my
life easier. And it also means I'm not going in with an immediate
bias. Guns blazing calls out. I think why I like Lauren is because
she's a good example of a stay-at-home mom who's found an outlet
in content creation that she's clearly having fun
Hey, as long as she's having fun because we love to see that.
Now, on the surface, Lauren's content looks very lifestylebased.
But as you scroll through her portfolio, you notice some things.
You notice that there's a teenage boy. Oh, her son is way older
than he should be. Uh oh.
Uh oh. I thought I somehow when I was hearing this or thinking
about this concept, I thought it was like a 10-year-old.
Uh
oh, this is going to be awkward. Who's always got a camera stuffed
in his face? Let me see it a little better. Hold on. Yes. Yes.
He's such a joy. Why didn't you get any length cut off the back?
You about got a rat tail.
you like it? Mhm. Huh? I think we needed to cut the back a little
bit more.
Yes.
It's okay. But no,
business in the front,
party in the back. And you realize that because Lauren's
life revolves around this teenage boy, a lot of her content also
revolves around this teenage boy, her son. And because these
videos get Lauren the most views, these videos are what has ultimately
transformed Lauren into what can be called a boy mom influencer.
Now, Lauren's clearly been through a lot in her life. And this
is something I see a lot with stereotypical boy moms. Their sons
are their everything, not just because they're their flesh and
blood. Okay, I've got to listen. I'm trying not to make judgments.
I have to take this in for a little bit. Commentary is going
to be a little light off the bat, okay? I have to take this in
and understand what I'm looking at here. Also, Kiddology is the
person presenting it. So, I'm not I'm not totally sure. I'm just
I'm trying not to call
I feel I feel very disconcerted. Okay. I feel like I'm at the
start of a horror movie right now. Like I' i've seen some flags.
I've seen some red flags, some some not green flags. Okay. I've
seen some stuff. I'm concerned, but I don't know what I'm also
because their sons were the only good thing that came out of
a bad relationship or the one good thing that came out of a hard
and difficult time in their life. I do also think that boy moms
get way more flak than their male equivalent because of course
women are blamed for everything wrong in society and oh cry about
it.
Okay. Are there a lot of uh dad daughters that are like borderline
eyeing their their daughters at all times? Is this a thing on
social media that we just allow and it's awesome? I feel like
that dynamic gets called up by the cops instantly. What are we
talking about?
Are you That's a thing in real life. That's like
that's our congressmen.
It's our state senators. Okay. Yeah, but they don't do tech talks
about it. Okay. Yes. But they don't do tech talks about it. They
don't do content about it. Okay. That's the difference. Okay.
They keep that in their daughter's bedroom where God intended.
I'm so so sorry. I got I gotta chill. I got I gota back all the
way up. Okay. That's they keep it off of social media. Okay.
They keep it off of social media. That's what this woman should
do. So, in all of this, I do have a bit of a soft spot for Lauren.
And yet, I think what makes Lauren so controversial is that she
clickbait being a boy mom, but she is also genuinely a boy mom
and doesn't seem to realize it. Don't he look cute carrying my
purse? What a gentleman.
I definitely just typed in his birthday
But Lauren is sort of like a new species of boy mom that until
now has gone pretty much under the radar on the internet. But
in order to wait, is Kadology Hold on.
Kiddology is like saying, "Oh, this person does satire on this
genre." Is Kiddology just like too autistic to understand what's
going on? Cuz I haven't seen the mom do something like super
weird yet. I stand this new species. We need to touch on the
rise and fall of the original stereotypical boy mom. Now, the
thing that I find so interesting about Lauren is that I think
she's sort of becoming the face of the new era of Tik Tok boy
moms. #boyom influencers have basically deserted the internet
on mass since article after article tore them to shreds back
in about mid 2023 to early 2024. And I would say that in 2025,
there is nothing worse for a mom on the internet than being branded
a boy mom. Maybe Karen is worse, but right now the stereotype
and label of boy mom is something that I'm quite sure every new
mother dreads because of Okay, I will just say this could be
true. I have no idea. Cadology is the person who like navigates
me